HELLO EVERYONE WE'RE GOING TO
START NOW.
OUR PROCEDURE WILL BE A LITTLE
DIFFERENT YOU CAN TELL MY VOICE
IS NOT NORMAL.
SO I VAST.
MY GOOD FRIEND AND VICE CHAIR.
MELISSA MELENDEZ TO. ARE
CONDUCTED GOOD PART OF THE
MEETING I WILL DO THE CLOTHES
BUT I WANT TO SAVE MY VOICE AT
THAT.
AND SO SHE WILL NOW NOT CALL UP.
THE FIRST PRESENTER.
IF WE HAVE SOMEONE HERE NOT YET
NOT WE HAVE ONE FOR A MINUTE.
DOING A SHOW OR DO ANY DO YOURS
GET EVER.
WELL SINCE WE DON'T HAVE ANY
OTHER AUTHORS HERE CHAIRMAN IS
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND PRESENT
HIS BILL WHICH IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR. A. B. TWO FOUR
SEVEN FOR
.
AND I GUESS I SHOULD MENTION WE
ARE OPERATING AS A SUB COMMITTEE
RIGHT NOW SINCE WE DON'T QUITE
HAVE A QUORUM BAKER HAD MR
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM VICE CHAIR.
.
AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY FOR
REQUIRES DTS SEE TO VALUE WAIT
AND ADOPT.
YOU MAIN OPTIONAL ALTERNATIVES.
THE CUTE.
CHRONIC TOXICITY TEST.
OR HAZARDOUS WASTE
IDENTIFICATION.
IF THEY MEET.
APARTMENTS NEED.
OR HAZARDOUS WASTE
IDENTIFICATION.
THE POINT IS THAT.
.
WE WANT THE DEPARTMENT TO DECIDE
WE'RE GOING TO SUGGEST SOME
TASKS BUT WE WANT TO DEPARTMENT
TO DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT THEY
ACTUALLY.
ACCOMPLISH.
WHAT'S NEEDED.
I I AND I WILL NOW LET MY
WITNESSES TESTIFY THANK YOU.
YOU HAVE FOUR MINUTES.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS CHRISTY
SOLVENT AND I'M A TOXICOLOGISTS
A CALIFORNIA RESIDENT AND THE
VICE PRESIDENT FOR RESEARCH
POLICY AT THE PHYSICIANS
COMMITTEE FOR RESPONSIBLE
MEDICINE. OR THE SPONSOR OF THIS
OF OF OF THIS BILL.
.
I CURRENTLY HAZARDOUS WASTES IS
TESTED THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
WITH A LIVE
FISH TASKS.
AND THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
PROBLEMS WITH THIS.
INCLUDING THAT FISH.
PUT UP WITH THE LIVE FISH.
COULD BE REPLACED WITH A COUPLE
OF ALTERNATIVES THAT ARE AS.
I HUGE I AS AN AN AN ISSUE WITH
RELATE REGARDS TO HUMANE USE OF
ANIMALS.
AND.
.
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
OFFERS DTS SEE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ASSESS ADVANCES AND TEST METHOD
DEVELOPMENT.
AND TOXICOLOGY PRACTICE TO TAKE
A MORE INTELLIGENT APPROACH TO
TOXICITY TESTING.
ANALYSES I'M GONNA TALK BRIEFLY
ABOUT ONE OF THE ALTERNATIVES
ANALYSES HAVE SHOWN THAT THE
DAPHNIA ARE SIMILAR TO FINISH.
AND IF A BIT MORE SENSITIVE TO
TOXIC MATERIALS.
THE TEST IS VERY SIMILAR TO THE
FISH ADULT TEST ARMED GROUPS OF
DAPHNIA ARE EXPOSED TO TEST
MATERIAL AND. SEVERAL DILUTIONS
AND THEN.
AND SEVERAL DILUTIONS AND AND
THE NUMBER OF IMMOBILIZE DAPHNE
ARE COUNTING AFTER TWENTY FOUR
OR FORTY EIGHT HOURS.
TOXIC OF A CERTAIN PERCENTAGE OF
DAPHNE A FAILED TO SURVIVE.
A DEATH NEAR IMPORTANT FOOD
SOURCE FOR FOR
ANOTHER QUANTIC ORGANISMS
MAKING THE DAPHNIA TOXICITY
TESTING INDICATOR OF POTENTIAL
AFFECTS.
OF A WASTE ON AQUATIC SYSTEMS
BEYOND THE SPECIFIC SPECIES OF
FISH USED IN THE LIVE FISH TO.
IN ADDITION TO CONSIDERATION OF
THE TWO TESTS ALTERNATIVES WE
SUGGEST IMPLEMENTING A TIERED
APPROACH THAT TAKES INTO ACCOUNT
CHEMICAL CHARACTERISTICS.
.
OF THE WASTE IN A TOWARD
DETERMINE WHAT IF ANY TESTING
SHOULD TAKE PLACE
RATHER THAN IMMEDIATELY GOING TO
THE LIVE.
THIS IS VERY COMMON PRACTICE IN
OTHER REGULATORY JURISDICTION.
IN MY OPINION THE TWO TESTS ARE
SCIENTIFICALLY APPROPRIATE AND
ARE LIKELY TO BE ADAPTABLE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S NEED. TO ENSURE THE
PROTECTION OF AQUATIC LIFE
AGAINST A RANGE OF VOLATILE
LIQUID AND SOLID WASTES WHILE
SAVING ANIMALS AND STATE RISK.
DAFFY OUR WATER FLEAS.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY. MY NAME IS
MARLA JEFFRIES AND I AM AN
ASSISTANT PROFESSOR OF BIOLOGY
AT TEXAS CHRISTIAN UNIVERSITY IN
FORT WORTH TEXAS.
I'VE BEEN CONDUCTING
TOXICOLOGICAL RESEARCH FOR
NEARLY FIFTEEN YEARS AND OVER
THE LAST SEVEN YEARS MUCH OF MY
RESEARCH HAS BEEN DEDICATED TO
EXAMINING THE UTILITY. OF THE
FAT ADMIN รณ FISH EMBRYO
TOXICITY TEST AS A REPLACEMENT
FOR TEST METHODS THAT REQUIRE
OLDER MORE DEVELOPED FISH.
IN PRACTICE THE FISH EMBRYO TEST
IS SIMILAR TO OTHER TESTS TYPES
GROUPS OF EMBRYOS ARE EXPOSED TO
SEVERAL DELUSIONS OF TEST
MATERIAL. AND THE NUMBER OF
EMBRYOS THAT PARISH ARE COUNTED
EVERY TWENTY FOUR HOURS FOR THE
DURATION OF THE TEST.
I THINK OFFICIALLY OF TOXICITY
TEST WAS ADOPTED BY THE OECD AND
TWENTY THIRTEEN. AS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO THE FISH ACUTE
TOXICITY TEST
A TEST SIMILAR TO THE STATIC
ACUTE BIO ACID BEING USED HERE
IN CALIFORNIA TO CLASSIFY
HAZARDOUS WASTES.
PRIOR TO THIS ADOPTION EXTENSIVE
VALIDATION EFFORTS WERE
UNDERTAKEN TO ENSURE THE
REPRODUCIBILITY AND SENSITIVITY
OF THE FISH EMBRYO TEST RELATIVE
TO THE FISH ACUTE TEST.
THESE EFFORTS REVEALED A STRONG
CORRELATION BETWEEN THE TWO
TESTS INDICATING THE POTENTIAL
FOR EMBRYOS TO BE UTILIZED IN
PLACE OF JUVENILE OR ADULT
FETCH.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
ALLOWS THE TT AS SEAT TO ASK AND
ANSWER THE QUESTION OF WHETHER
THESE TO TEST TYPES.
WHICH INCLUDES THE FISH EMBRYO
TO.
TOXICITY TEST CAN MEET THE
DEMANDS OF THEIR HAZARDOUS WASTE
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM.
IN MY PROFESSIONAL OPINION THAT
YOU TEST OF THE POTENTIAL TO
MEET THEIR NEEDS ENSURING THE
PROTECTION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY
ENHANCING THE WELFARE OF ANIMALS
UTILIZED IN THE ASSOCIATED
TOXICITY.
THANK YOU AND OUR FINAL WITNESS.
HOLLY FOR MANY WITH WHITE HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
SOCIAL COMPASSION AND
LEGISLATION THE CO SPONSOR OF
SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT WELL THAT WAS EASY.
ANYONE ELSE ONE COME FORWARD
AND SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
PLEASE COME FORWARD NOW.
OR FOREVER HOLD YOUR PEACE.
OKAY IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. IF SO PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
NOBODY.
WHILE.
GOOD JOB CHAIRMAN QUIRK NO
OPPOSITION.
THIS IS GONNA SAVE YOUR VOICE A
LITTLE BIT OKAYED SO.
SINCE
IT IS ONLY ME ON THE DIET IS AND
I DON'T HAVE ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS I'M OTHER THAN TO SAY
I'M IMPRESSED DID YOUR WITNESS
COME ALL THE WAY FROM TEXAS.
TO TESTIFY.
WELL YOU GET THE AWARD FOR
TRAVELING THE FURTHEST FOR
TESTIFYING TODAY.
OKAY WELL I THINK THIS MAKES
PERFECT SENSE AMMANAI WOULD
NEVER DARE TO CHALLENGE A
CHAIRMAN QUIRK ON ANYTHING
SCIENTIFIC BECAUSE I KNOW WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IF I DID. AMBER
THIS MAKES PRETTY PRETTY GOOD
SENSE TO ME.
SO I WOULD MOVE THE BILL IF I
COULD BUT I CAN NOT SO WHEN THE
REST OF OUR MEMBERS.
ENTER THE CHAMBERS AND TAKE
THEIR SEATS THEN I'LL BE HAPPY
MOVE THAT BILL.
WITH THAT MUCH MISTER COURT DO
YOU WANT TO MOVE ON TO.
YOUR ALLERGIST CLOSE I'M SORRY
YOUR CLOTHES I APOLOGIZE OKAY SO
WHETHER YOU ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE DEATH OF NANO CERTAIN NOT.
MANY COMMERCIAL LA ENTITIES ARE
CONCERNED.
BECAUSE THEIR CUSTOMERS ARE
CONCERNED AND THEY WANT TO GET A
LABEL.
SAYS.
CRUELTY ENAMEL CRUELTY FREE.
SO I URGE YOU VOTE.
I.
THOUGHT SHE SURE WE CAN GO ON TO
THE NEXT ONE.
OKAY SO THEN THE NEXT ONE IS.
FILE ITEM EIGHT WHICH IS AB TWO
SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN.
MISTER TING IS HERE SO HE IS
HERE OKAY.
IRATE MR TING.
COME ON UP.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TWO
FOUR ZERO SEVEN.
AND WE HAVE A SUBCOMMITTEE RIGHT
NOW IT'S JUST MEAL CHAIRMAN
NOBEL THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MISTER CHAIR. OF VERY QUICKLY AB
ARE TWENTY FOUR SEVEN TASK THE
SECRETARY FOR ENVIRONMENT
PROTECTION TO CONVENE THE
LITHIUM ION. CAR BATTERY
RECYCLING ADVISORY GROUP DEVICE
SUPPORT GROUP REVIEW AND ADVISE
THE LEGISLATURE ON POLICIES
PERTAINING TO THE RECOVERY AND
RECYCLING A LITHIUM ION VEHICLE
BATTERY SOLD WITH MOTOR
VEHICLES.
THESE POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS TO
LEGISLATURE WOULD BE DUE APRIL
ONE TWENTY TWENTY I KNOW OUR
MINORITY LEADER MISTER DALI ALSO
HAS A SIMILAR BILL. WE ARE WE'VE
BEEN IN CONVERSATIONS AND SHOULD
OUR BILLS BOTH BE TO SENATE WE
OP SICKEN ME COMPLETELY
COMMITTED. TO WORKING TOGETHER
TO RESOLVE PHAM THE VERY FEW
DIFFERENCES WE HAVE. AND A
COMBINED EFFORT SO WE ARE
ACTUALLY COMMITTED TO DOING THAT
AND APPRECIATE HIM FOR. OUR
REACHING OUT. HOW GREAT I'M GLAD
TO HEAR THAT THANK YOU?
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE OKAY ANYONE
WITNESS WITNESS.
I AM A CLUB OF CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE. ARE WE CURRENTLY
HAVE ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ELECTRIC VEHICLES ON THE ROAD
OUT OF THIRTY FIVE MILLION CARS.
BUT THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE
ORDER IS PROJECTED TO INCREASE
THAT FIVE MILLION BY TWENTY
THIRTY. AND THAT THE AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL HAS LEGISLATION TO
TRANSITION TO ALL ELECTRIC
VEHICLES BY TWENTY FORTY.
SO REALLY WE HAVE A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO GET AHEAD.
ABOUT MAJOR RECYCLING ISSUE
AND COME UP WITH A COHERENT
STRATEGY FOR MANAGING.
THE BATTERIES THAT COME WITH
THESE CARS BEFORE THEY BECOME A
PROBLEM.
AND SO WE COMMAND AUTHOR FOR
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE.
TACKLE IT NOW NOT WAIT UNTIL THE
END OF LIFE FOR THESE VEHICLES.
THANK YOU ARM ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES YOU WANT TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
OKAY ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES YOU
WANT TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL.
NOPE OKAY ON. I DON'T MISTER
CHAIRMAN YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS
YOU WANT TO JUST CLOSE IT OUT
FOR THEM.
THANK YOU FOR AGREEING TO MAKE
IT WORK WITH MISTER DALI.
THE TWO OF YOU WOULD BE IN AND
BE ABLE TO.
I ORIGINALLY VOTE THANK YOU.
AND. WE WILL OBVIOUSLY WHEN WE
HAVE MORE MEMBERS MOVE THE BILL
IN AND VOTE ON IT BUT THANK YOU
VERY PAYING VERY MUCH PUSH.
WHEN I WAS HERE.
THIS OF MISTER CHAIRMAN WITH
WHICH YOU LIKE TO PRESENT YOUR
SECOND BILL.
COMMITTEE HEARING
.
WELL I'LL JUST START FROM
MEMORY.
SO ORIGINALLY HAD A BILL.
WHICH.
ASKED TO BAN CERTAIN LEAD
WEIGHTS.
BOUGHT THE INDUSTRY CAME TO ME
WITH A CONCERNED. WHILE THERE
IS.
CERTAINLY.
A LOT OF EVIDENCE THAT THEY ARE
LET THIS IS LEAD FISHING
WEIGHTS.
THERE'S CERTAINLY A LOT OF
EVIDENCE THAT LEAD FISHING
WEIGHTS.
.
ARE CAUSING PROBLEMS IN
PARTICULAR POPULATIONS BALLOONS
IN VARIOUS AREAS.
THEY WANTED TO KNOW.
WHETHER OR NOT IT REALLY WOULD
CAUSE A PROBLEM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND ALSO EXACTLY WHAT THE WEIGHT
OF A FISHING WEIGHT WE.
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT IF WE WERE
TO BAN CERTAIN WAY TO FISHING
WEIGHTS WE WERE LOOKING AT THE
SMALLER WEIGHTS WHICH ARE THE
ONES.
THEY CAN BE EATEN BY DOCS THAT
FEED ON THE BOTTOM.
SO THAT I THINK THEY RAISED
VALID CONCERNS.
WE ARE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
EXACTLY WHAT THAT TARA WEIGHT
LIMIT SHOULD BE.
SO I'VE AGREED TO WORK WITH THE
INDUSTRY TO DO A STUDY TO LOOK
PRECISELY.
AT WHAT THE RISKS ARE IN
CALIFORNIA.
I WILL BE ASKING THE.
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO
APPROVE THAT AND ALSO WORKING ON
THE BUDGET.
AND WITH THAT.
WHEN WE HAVE A CORE. CLASS FOR
NINE VOTE
SO YOU ARE TAKING THE AMENDMENTS
IN THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
NOT MISS CAMINO.
I'M TAKING THEM AS SOON AS I
CAN THERE RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE SO WILL WE'RE CHANGING
MY OWN BILL TO A STUDY BALLOT
CAN YOU IMAGINE THAT I'VE BEEN
THERE BUT IT'S THE RIGHT THING
TO DO.
ONE MAKE SURE WE ARE CLEAR.
SURE THE CHAIR TELL ME I HAD TO
DO IT.
HE'S PIECE.
CIRCULAR LAKE VADYM AM OKAY SO
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES WHO
WANT TO COME FORWARD AND TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION.
MADAM.
MADAM CHAIRWOMAN MEMBERS MARK
SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
SPORTFISHING ASSOCIATION. THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA GUIDES AND
SPORTSMEN'S.
AB VARIETY OF OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS AS PART OF A
LARGER COALITION WHO WILL
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES COMING UP.
ON NOT HARD OPPOSITION BUT I
THINK WE STILL ARE IN A POSITION
WHERE WE DO NOT HAVE AGREEMENT
WITH THE AUTHOR ON.
THE SCOPE OF THE LANGUAGE FOR
THE STUDY THAT IS PROPOSED IN
THIS PARTICULAR BILL. AYE WE DO
RECOGNIZE THE FACT THAT. THE
AUTHOR HAS AMENDED THE BILL TO
ELIMINATE THE BAND AND WE ARE
VERY APPRECIATIVE THAT SOMEHOW
WE THINK THAT THE BAND WAS
PROBABLY HAVE A PREMATURE
CONVERSATION TO BE HAVING AT
THIS POINT IN TIME.
WE DID PROPOSE SOME LANGUAGE
THAT WE FELT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE FOR A STUDY. ARE
INCLUDING THE FACT THAT WE WOULD
REALLY LIKE A STUDY TO LOOK AT
POPULATION LEVEL AFFECTS.
WE DON'T WANT TO SUGGEST DOING
ANYTHING RELATIVE TO BANNING A
PARTICULAR PRODUCT.
IF THE INDIVIDUAL OCCURRENCES
ARE SO INFREQUENT AS TO BE ARE
NOT SIGNIFICANT ON A POPULATION
LEVEL AFFECTED SO. WE PROPOSE
SOME LANGUAGE RELATIVE TO THAT
THE AUTHORS PROPOSE SOME OTHER
LANGUAGE AT THIS POINT IN TIME I
THINK OUR COALITION WOULD LIKE
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH HIM AS
THE BILL MOVES FORWARD TO REACH
AGREEMENT ON WHAT THAT LANGUAGE
SHOULD LOOK LIKE SO. A SOFT
OPPOSE AT THIS POINT IN TIME BUT
AGAIN DO WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHORS OFFICE AND THE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THIS ISSUE
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS A
GEORGE OSBORNE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA SPORTFISHING LEAGUE.
AND THE CO SIDE FISHING CLUB
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR OF
YOU HAVING A GOOD DAY. MADAM
VICE CHAIR AND.
THE MEMBERS. FOR HER OF HER
HERE.
FIRST LET ME SAY WE RESPECT THE
AUTHOR.
AND HIS CONCERN FOR WILDLIFE.
WE SHARE THAT CONCERN.
A SPORTING LORS BY THE VERY
NATURE A CONSERVATIONIST
WHO APPRECIATE THE RULES
GOVERNING OUR SPORT.
TO ENSURE THE FUTURE GENERATIONS
OF ANGLERS
OUR CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN.
I HAVE A HEALTHY POPULATION OF
WILDLIFE INCLUDING FISH TO ENJOY
AND TAKE.
I TO US IT IS VERY SIMPLE. NO
FISH MEANS NO FUTURE ANGLERS.
THE GREEN CHEMISTRY INITIATIVE
PASSED OUT OF THE LEGISLATURE IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT IN A CHARGE
THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCE CONTROL WITH
IDENTIFYING. AND PRIORITIZING
CHEMICALS OF CONCERN IN CONSUMER
PRODUCTS.
AND THE BEST POSSIBLE
ALTERNATIVES AND TO TAKE
REGULATORY ACTION TO BEST
PROTECT PEOPLE. AND THE
ENVIRONMENT.
THE LEGISLATURE TOOK THAT ACTION
IN PART
TO TAKE POLITICS OUT OF THIS
DISCUSSION AND LET SCIENCE BE
THE GUY.
I FIRST ENGAGED AN ISSUE OF LEAD
FISHING TACKLE IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN WHEN DGSE PUT LED FINISH
FISHING TACKLE. AT THE FRONT OF
THE LINE ON THEIR PRIORITY
PRODUCTS LIST.
MY CLIENTS OPPOSED TO BEING
PLACED ON THAT LIST.
AMONG OTHER REASONS BECAUSE
THERE IS NO SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH.
DONE IN CALIFORNIA THAT
INDICATED THAT LEAD WEIGHTS AND
SINKERS.
WE'RE CAUSING ANY PROBLEMS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AFTER A GREAT OUTCRY FROM
RECREATIONAL ENGLAND COMMUNITY.
DGSE PUT THE ISSUE OF LEAD
FISHING TACKLE AT THE BACK OF
THE LINE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
STARTED OUT AS A BAND ON LEAD
AND FISHING WEIGHTS AND SINKERS
EVEN THOUGH WE'RE STILL HAS
BEEN.
NO RESEARCH IN CALIFORNIA THAT
POINTS TO LEAD FISHING WEIGHTS
AND SINKERS IS HAVING A NEGATIVE
IMPACT THAN ANY WILDLIFE
POPULATION. IN CALIFORNIA.
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN IS
A BAN ON LEAD WEIGHTS AND
SINKERS. ALSO GENERATED NOW
OUTPOURING OF OPPOSITION AS YOU
CAN SEE FROM YOUR ANALYSIS AS
WELL AS THE FIFTY FIVE HUNDRED
CALIFORNIA ANGLERS WHO SIGN THE
ONLINE PETITION. OPPOSING THE
BAN.
IN OUR DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR HE BROACHED THE IDEA OF A
RESEARCH STUDY. TO IDENTIFY
WHERE PROBLEM MAY EXIST IN
CALIFORNIA TO WILDLIFE.
BECAUSE THE THE USE OF LEAD
WEIGHTS AND SINKERS.
WHAT WE DO NOT OBJECT TO SUCH A
RESEARCH STUDY THE PARAMETERS OF
STUDY MUST BE WELL DEFINED?
PAN AND LIMITED WE BELIEVE TO
THE POTENTIAL EFFECTS ON
WILDLIFE POPULATIONS FROM THE
USE OF LEAD WEIGHTS AND SINKERS.
THAT'S WHY WE CONTINUE O OPPOSE
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN AS
IT IS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED
HEARING COMMITTEE TODAY.
WE OPPOSE YET ANOTHER UNFUNDED
MANDATE UNDER DEPARTMENT FISH
AND WILDLIFE. AND BELIEVE IT'S A
SOURCE OF FUNDING SHOULD BE
INCLUDED IN THE BILL.
STUDY SHOULD BE LIMITED TO THE
IMPACTS ON WILDLIFE POPULATIONS
WHERE SUCH AN IMPACT MAY OCCUR.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE STUDY SHOULD
BE CONDUCTED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE AND NOT
CONTRACTED OUT.
TO WHAT MAY BE ULTIMATELY THE
LOWEST BIDDER.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS AN
OUTSTANDING SCIENTIST IN HOUSE.
WHO WITH THE APPROPRIATE FUNDING
COULD MOST EFFECTIVELY STUDY THE
IMPACT OF LEAD AND FISHING
WEIGHTS? AND SINKERS ON WILDLIFE
POPULATIONS.
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO.
THE ISSUE OF HUMAN HEALTH WE
BELIEVE WOULD BE BETTER LEFT TO
ANOTHER LEGISLATIVE VEHICLE. AS
A DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE IS ALREADY RELATED TO
US.
THAT HUMAN HEALTH ISSUES ARE
BEYOND THEIR JURISDICTION.
WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO MEET AND DIALOGUE
WITH US. WE HOPE TO CONTINUE
THESE DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR TO EVENTUALLY COME TO AN
AGREEMENT ON THE PARAMETERS OF
THE SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH STUDY.
AND I THINK ONE OF THE. MOST
IMPORTANT FACTORS IS TO HELP THE
AUTHOR IDENTIFY THE SOURCE OF
FUNDING
WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH THEM A
GOING FORWARD ON AT. A BUT FOR
NOW WE MUST OPPOSE THE AUTHORS
PROPOSED STUDY LANGUAGE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO.
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANY
ONE ELSE WHO WISHES TO COME
FORWARD AND TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
NOW OKAY SO I ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM.
WE DO WELL. SNEAKING IT FROM THE
BACK TO LINE UP.
NAME.
ORGANIZATION IN YOUR POSITION
AT REGULARLY WITHOUT CHAMBER
WERE ALSO IN OPPOSITION TO THE
PROPOSED AMENDED LANGUAGE AND. I
THINK YOU.
NO ONE ELSE
GOOD AFTERNOON CAPTAIN WENT
REPRESENTING COMPANIES
SPORTSMEN'S LOBBY OUTDOOR SPORTS
WAS COALITION AND SPIKELET
INTERNATIONAL IN THE SAME
POSITION AS THE WITNESS THANK
YOU.
SO ANNOUNCEMENT THE
CONGRESSIONAL SPORTS FOUNDATION
ALSO.
STRELA SENTIMENTS OF THE
WITNESS.
AND THE UP AND BREAK LEAD FILTHY
WITH APEX GRUPA ON BEHALF OF
THE.
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
MANUFACTURERS AND UP
CALIFORNIA'S.
YUP BROKERS ASSOCIATION.
THE MARINE RECREATION
ASSOCIATION WE ARE ALSO POST.
ALRIGHT ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
NO OKAY SOBERING APPEARED TO DIS
FOR DISCUSSION.
NOW NOTHING OKAY.
WELL I I THINK THAT.
THE OPPOSITION BRINGS UP SOME
VALID POINTS I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND YOUR CONCERN.
I THINK CHAIRMAN QUIRK.
IT'S BEEN MY EXPERIENCE HE'S
PRETTY GOOD ABOUT WORKING WITH
THE OPPOSITION TO MAKE SURE THAT
I'M EVERYBODY'S HAPPY WITH THIS
IN THE AND. THE AMENDMENTS ARE
THAT THIS WILL TURN INTO A STUDY
BILL WHICH I ASSUME YOU WILL
WORK CLOSELY THROUGHOUT THIS
PROCESS SO THAT IT IS THEM.
ADEQUATELY FUNDED.
INAPPROPRIATELY FOCUSED ON ON
WHERE IT SHOULD BE SO HOW WE DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM SO WE CANNOT
VOTE RIGHT NOW WE CAN'T EVEN
MOVE THE BILL RIGHT NOW.
BUT THERE MAY BE.
FURTHER DISCUSSION LATER BUT AT
THIS POINT GENTLEMEN I THINK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
AND.
MISTER QUIRK IF YOU STILL HAVE A
LOANS I WELCOME. I AGREE WE HAVE
TO.
TO GET MONEY IN THE BUDGET
OTHERWISE HE DON'T EXPECT TO GET
THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS.
ARM SO WILL WILL DEFINITELY BE
TRYING TO GET MONEY IN THE
BUDGET FOR THIS.
AND I ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE I
HAVE A STUDY THAT MAKES A GOOD
CASE.
AND SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO TAKE
A LOOK AT THAT IF MY TIME IS TOO
SHORT AND IT DOESN'T COME UP
WITH A.
DEFINITIVE ANSWER THEN WE WILL
NEED MORE TIME BUT. BUT LET'S
JUST WORK ON THIS OVER THE NEXT
FEW WEEKS AND.
BILL IS GOING TO APPROPRIATIONS
HOPEFULLY BEFORE IT'S OUT COLD
LA WE CAN DECIDE ON WHERE WE'RE
GOING THANK YOU OKAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU GENERAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY I REALIZE IT'S A
LITTLE ANTI CLIMACTIC ALWAYS
HOPE VOTE I APOLOGIZE BUT WE THE
PEOPLE HERE.
.
MISTER MURATSUCHI DO YOU.
THE WAITRESS COMING.
MISTER SOUNDS HERE THE AREAS.
ASSEMBLYMAN STONE COME ON UP.
M. FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN AB TWO
NINE THREE FOUR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY FOUR IS A
BILL THAT WOULD FACILITATE.
THE NUMBER OF INSPECTORS WHO ARE
BE WILL BE NECESSARY FOR GOING
OUT LOOKING INTO OUR COMMUNITIES
AND FINDING LEAD PAINT THAT'S
THERE. THERE WAS A RECENT.
SUPREME COURT DECISION THAT
AWARDED TEN COUNTIES.
THAT SETTLED THE A A SETTLEMENT
THEY GAVE THEM A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF MONEY FROM THE LEAD PAINT
COMPANIES BECAUSE OF THE TOXIC
MATERIALS IT'S IN A LOT OF
PEOPLE'S HOUSES. AND THERE'S NOT
CURRENTLY THE AND ENOUGH
INSPECTORS ACROSS ALL OF THE
COUNTIES WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
FACILITATE THAT. THE STATE
WORKING WITH THE COUNTIES TO
ENSURE THAT THERE ARE
APPROPRIATE NUMBER OF INSPECTORS
OUT IN OUR COMMUNITY SO WE CAN
GET THE WORK DONE WE GET THE
MONEY SPENT WE CAN GET. THE
DANGEROUS SITUATION AND A LOT OF
THESE HOMES REMEDIATED AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE I AM HAPPY TO TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE. OFFERED IN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND I
THINK THAT REALLY HELPS. TO
COORDINATE THE ISSUE WITH
RESPECT TO THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THE STATE GOVERNMENT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE A PROCESS WHERE WE CAN
GET THIS DONE AS EXPEDITIOUSLY.
AS POSSIBLE.
WONDERFUL AND YOU ARE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT YES
JENNY LAM FROM THE COUNTY
COUNSEL'S OFFICE IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY. THE COUNTY SANTA CLARA
IS PLEASED TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY
NINE THIRTY FOR ALMOST TWENTY
YEARS AGO OUR OFFICE FILED ITS
LANDMARK CASE TO HOLD FORMER LED
PETE MANUFACTURERS ACCOUNTABLE.
FOR PROMOTING ON A WIDESPREAD
BASIS THE USE OF LEAD PAINT IN
HOMES DESPITE KNOWING THAT THEIR
PRODUCT WAS TOXIC AND HARMFUL TO
CHILDREN. JOINING INSIGHTS IN
THIS FIGHT WERE NINE OTHER
CITIES IN COUNTY INCLUDING
ALAMEDA COUNTY LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. CITY OF OAKLAND MONTEREY
COUNTY CITY OF SAN DIEGO SAN
FRANCISCO SAN THEM CEMETERY
KENNY SOLANO COUNTY IN VENTURA
COUNTY.
HAVING NOW WANNA HISTORIC
JUDGMENT AGAINST THE FORMER LEAD
PAINT MANUFACTURERS WE NOW NEED
YOUR HELP TO IMPLEMENT THE
COURT'S DECISION IN SHORT LEAD
SAFE HOUSING FOR THE CHILDREN OF
OUR STATE.
EVERY YEAR THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN
ARE POISONED BY LEAD ACROSS THE
STATE. DIDN'T FROM TWO THOUSAND
TEN THROUGH TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN THE LAST FIVE YEARS FOR
WHICH THERE IS DATA AVAILABLE
JUST IMITATING JURISDICTIONS
THAT I'VE NAMED ALMOST FORTY
THOUSAND CHILDREN WORK TESTED
POSITIVE FOR LEAD POISONING.
THE EFFECTS OF LEAD POISONING
ARE PERMANENT AND IRREVERSIBLE
SO EVERYONE OF THOSE CHILDREN IS
IRREVERSIBLY AFFECTED FOR LIFE.
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
REPORTS THAT AT HIGH LEVELS OF
EXPOSURE LEAD POISONING CAN
RESULT IN DEATH COMA. AT AND
CONVULSIONS
CHILDREN WHO SURVIVE SEVERE LEAD
POISONING MAY BE LEFT WITH
MENTAL RETARDATION BEHAVIORAL
DISORDERS.
AND AT LOWER LEVELS OF EXPOSURE.
AT WHICH THERE ARE NO OBVIOUS
SYMPTOMS LEAD CAN AFFECT
CHILDREN'S BRAIN DEVELOPMENTS IN
RESERVE RESULTING IN REDUCED IQ
BEHAVIORAL CHANGES SUCH AS
REDUCED ATTENTION SPAN AND
REDUCED EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT.
THE EXPERTS ALL AGREE THAT LEAD
PAINT IS THE PREDOMINANT SOURCE
OF LEAD POISONING FOR CHILDREN.
LEAD PAINT DETERIORATES LIKE ALL
PAINS AND CONTAMINATES THE AIR
THE SOIL THE FLOORS AND OTHER
SURFACES IN HOMES
DURING TRIAL ONE OF OUR EXPERTS
TESTIFIED. THAT IT THE INJECTION
OF A PINK SHIP THE SIZE OF A
PERIOD AT THE END OF A SENTENCE
IS ENOUGH TO CAUSE. LEAD
POISONING THAT WOULD PERMANENTLY
DAMAGED OPERATE A YOUNG WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT THE BILL.
IT'S ABOUT MORE RESPECTED MORE
INSPECTORS.
SO I WE DON'T NEED TO HEAR I
THINK A LOT MORE ABOUT LAND I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING WE CAN
AGREE ON.
I IT REALLY IS ABOUT THE ONLY
THE INSPECTORS
YES
AND THE JUDGMENT CREATES A HUGE
DEMAND AND AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PREVENT CHILDHOOD LEAD POISONING
FOR THE TEN JURISDICTIONS IN OUR
STATE AND INVOLVED IN OUR CASE.
AND OVER A VERY SHORT OPERATE AT
THE OVER A VERY SHORT TIME FRAME
IS THERE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
DEBATE LEAD PAINT AND I
JURISDICTIONS. AND SO WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL AND
IF IT DIDN'T THE SHORTAGE OF
CERTIFIED WORKERS IS CLEAR AT
THE NEED IS URGENT AND WE. AND
WE WOULD HOPE THAT THE STATE
TAKES AND WHATEVER ACTIONS IT
CAN TO INCREASE AND EXPAND THE
WORK FORCE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
COME FORWARD.
O. WE HAVE A QUORUM NOW SO WOULD
YOU PLEASE TAKE THEIR ALL.
BEFORE THEY ESCAPE.
QUIRK.
HERE QUIRK IS HERE MELENDEZ HERE
MELINDA'S IS HERE ARAMBULA.
BRO.
BLOOM.
HOLDEN.
HOLDINGS HERE
MORETZ WOULD CHEER RATS WHICH IS
HERE WE HAVE A QUORUM.
OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM ACCENT NOW
WE CAN GET SOME WORK DONE OKAY
BACK TO THE SUPPORT. I DIDN'T
SEE ANYONE ELSE COMING FORWARD
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
IF THERE IS PLEASE COME FORWARD.
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION TO YOUR
BILL THAT'S.
WOW THIS IS THE COMMITTEE TO BE
AN IF YOU WANNA PRESENT A BILL
OKAY SO SINCE THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION FROM THE DIET IS.
OKAY A MOVE IN IT AND A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
.
DO I CLOSE MISTER STONE AND THEN
PERHAPS OTHER GERMAN WOULD
WANNA.
AT ANYTHING.
ALL ALL ALL JUST POINT OUT THAT.
IF FOR SUMMER. WE NEED THESE
PEOPLE WHETHER OR NOT.
THERE IS A LAWSUIT AND I KNOW
THE LAWSUIT IS STILL BEING
ARGUED ABOUT.
WE ALSO WILL NEED THEM IF FOR
SOME REASON THE LEAD COMPANIES
PROPOSITION GOES THROUGH AND WE
HAVE TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN
STATE MONEY.
SO THESE PEOPLE ARE NEEDED THAT
NO MATTER WHAT YOUR POSITION ON
THAT LAWSUIT AND SO I URGE NOT
VOTE.
OKAY SO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND MAN I'M.
HE DID DO IS CLOSE YES FOR.
A CELL PHONE TO CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER TEN. AB
TWENTY NINE THIRTY FOUR MARK
STONE. THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
QUIRK.
I QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ.
MULLIN DOES NOT VOTING I'M GLAD.
BRO.
BLOOM.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I WHAT OUT SEARCHING.
MINUTES WATCHING I.
THREE VOTES.
SO THAT BILL IS ON CALL WE'RE
JUST WAITING FOR THEIR MEMBERS
HERE RIGHT.
RIGHT WHILE WE'RE WAITING FOR
AUTHORS ARE MADAM SECRETARY CAN
WE GO THROUGH.
THE OTHER BILLS HAD BEEN
PRETENDED.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
TWENTY FOUR OH SEVEN TING.
QUIRK MAY TELL THE MOTION IS TO
PASS.
รณ WE NEED TO MODE HAVE A
MOTION I'M SORRY WE ARE STARTING
WE HAVE A QUORUM NOW SO WE'RE
GONNA START.
BASICALLY TAKING.
VOTES ON THESE BILLS SO IT'S A.
SO WE NEED A MOTION.
SO MELENDEZ IS.
WHAT'S WHICH
OKAY.
SORRY.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER THREE.
AB TWENTY FOUR OH SEVENTEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS
QUIRK I.
QUIRK HIGH
MELENDEZ.
MELINDA'S AYE ARAMBULA.
PEROT.
BLOOM.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
MY IT'S A CHEAP ROUTE SWITCHING.
SO WE HAVE FOUR VOTES.
I WILL MOVE IF ITEM NUMBER FIVE
AB TWO FOUR SEVEN FOR.
OKAY.
IT WAS HOLDEN.
OKAY THE.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY FOUR.
QUIRK.
I.
MELENDEZ AYE.
MOMENT AS I ARAMBULA.
BRO.
BLOOM HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
MATTEUCCI.
WHAT I FUJI I SWEAR FOR VOTES?
CAN I WILL MOVE. ITEM EIGHT AB
TWO SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN.
THEIR SECOND.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN.
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ AYE
MELINDA'S AYE AROUND BELOW.
BRO.
BLOOM.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I WOULD AT SWITCHING
MERTZ WATCHING.
FOR.
SO DO WE WANT TO HAVE.
WE HAVE.
MISTER MURATSUCHI PRESENT
.
I.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FIRST FOR
WORKING GO ON THIS BILL AND WE
LIKE TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
THAT'S OUTLINED IN THE NLCS.
BY THIS BILL A. B. TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTEEN REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT
OF PESTICIDE REGULATION.
TWO ONE CONDUCTING EVALUATION OF
THE HEALTHY SCHOOLS ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND.
BUT TO SEE WHERE WE'RE AT IN
TERMS OF THE.
.
THAT DID THE STATUS OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN IMPLEMENTING THIS
ACT.
AND SECOND TO RECOMMEND TO THE
LEGISLATURE WHETHER ONE OR MORE
PESTICIDES SHOULD BE RESTRICTED
OR PROHIBITED.
BY I FIRST BECAME INVOLVED IN
THIS ISSUE.
WHEN.
NINE ISSUE WAS RAISED THAT MY
OWN DAUGHTERS TO A PUBLIC
SCHOOL.
ARE WHERE.
THEY USE OF PESTICIDES THAT MY
DAUGHTER'S SCHOOL OF SCHOOL
FIELDS AND I WAS SUSPENDED AFTER
NUMEROUS.
I COMPLAINTS OF CHILDREN HAVING
GO.
I AND SKIN IRRITATION A BRIEFING
PROBLEMS.
AND AND SO THERE WAS A.
A OUR A LOCAL UPROAR.
IN MY SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AROUND THE USE OF PESTICIDES
THAT ARE OUR DAUGHTER'S SCHOOL
AT MY DAUGHTER'S SCHOOL.
WELL AS WE ALL KNOW PESTICIDES
CAN CAUSE A VARIETY OF HEALTH
PROBLEMS ACCORDING TO THE UNITED
STATES ENVIRONMENT PROTECTION
AGENCY.
THAT'S ASIDE EXPOSURE CAN CAUSE
DIZZINESS NAUSEA A TO SERIOUS
LONG TERM NEUROLOGICAL AND
REPRODUCTIVE DISORDERS.
FURTHERMORE THE NATIONAL
ACADEMY OF SCIENCES HAVE
REPORTED THAT.
CHILDREN IN PARTICULAR ARE MORE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO CHEMICALS.
THAN ADULTS AN ESTIMATE THAT UP
TO
PERCENT OF LIFETIME PARA
PESTICIDE EXPOSURE.
OCCURS DURING THE FIRST FIVE
YEARS OF LIFE.
IN A RECENT COURT RULING
CALIFORNIA CAN NOW LISTS.
BLOG LIKE THE STATE COMMENTED
HERBICIDE SUCH AS ROUNDUP AS A
LIKELY CARCINOGEN. UNDER
PROPOSITION SIXTY FIVE.
MORE MORE EVIDENCE IS FINDING
IT PESTICIDES CAN BE DANGEROUS
ESPECIALLY TO CHILDREN.
AS I INDICATED EARLIER.
THIS BILL WILL PROTECT OUR
CHILDREN BY LOOKING AT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE HEALTHY
SCHOOLS ACT IN OUR SCHOOLS.
A WHICH IS NOT BEEN EVALUATED
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TEN.
TO ENSURE PROPER IMPLEMENTATION
AND TO CONSIDER CERTAIN PATHS
SITES THAT SHOULD. BE BANNED OR
RESTRICTED.
I HAVE TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL AND.
ELECT FIRST TRIED OVER THE
DOCTOR MICHELLE PARA.
A PEDIATRICIAN WHO'S BEEN.
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE FOR MANY
YEARS.
ASSEMBLYMAN
A THANK YOU BY CHAIRPERSON QUIRK
AND ASSEMBLYMEMBERS I'M GLAD TO
BE HERE TODAY. I'VE BEEN A
BEDOUIN PEDIATRICIAN FOR NEARLY
FOUR DECADES AND ON THE
FRONTLINE PEDIATRICIAN WHICH
MEANS MY HANDS GOES ON PATIENTS
AND I ACTUALLY. EXAMINE PATIENTS
AND WORK IN THE CLIPPINGS A
CLINIC SETTING I RECENTLY WROTE
THIS BOOK WITH A COLLEAGUE WHICH
I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU. A
ASSEMBLYMAN QUIRK REGARDING THE
HEALTH OF OUR CHILDREN A WITH
THE FOCUS ON QUITE THE STATE
WHICH IS MY AREA OF EXPERTISE
WHICH I'VE BEEN STUDYING FOR
ABOUT TWELVE YEARS.
THIS BOOK IS BASED ON MY
PATIENTS MOSTLY MARIN COUNTY AND
THE SOME OF THE SURROUNDING
AREAS. AND AS YOU ALREADY KNOW
MARIN COUNTY IS THE EIGHTH
WEALTHIEST COUNTY IN THE U. S.
SO I'M TAKING CARE VERY AFFLUENT
CHILDREN WHO HAVE ACCESS TO
MEANS. NOW THERE ARE EIGHT
COUNTIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT DON'T HAVE
ACCESS SUCH AS FRESNO MERCED
CURRENT TO OUR IMPERIAL MERCED
ON LAKE IT CETERA. AND THESE
COUNTIES HAVE HIGH RATES OF A
SPRING BOTH IN THE AGRICULTURAL
FIELD.
PARENTS BRINGING THE SPRING
HOME TO CHILDREN AND THE
CHILDREN ARE ADDITIONALLY BEING
SPRAYED AT SCHOOL. THIS
POPULATION IS MOSTLY LATINO AND
THEY HAVE SOME OF THE HIGHEST
RATES OF ILLNESS IN THE STATE
AND WE HAVE GOOD SCIENTIFIC DATA
SUPPORTING THAT.
SO THEN THERE BECOMES AN ISSUE
ABOUT OR CULTURAL AND
EDUCATIONAL JUSTICE AS WELL
WHICH IS ONE OF MY CONCERNS I
BRING FOR WHICH THIS COMMITTEE.
WHEN WE LOOK BACK AT THE WORK OF
ASSEMBLY MARTUCCI AND WHAT
HAPPENED IN HIS CHILD'S SCHOOL
WITH THAT WE KNOW THAT EVEN
SINGLE SPRING OF ACUTE SPRING
CAN CAUSE LONG TERM SQUARELY IN
PARTICULAR CANCERS. CANCERS TAKE
A LONG TIME DEVELOP AT AS UP AS
HIGH AS TWO DECADES.
SO NOBODY WILL ABLE TO OF ANY OF
THOSE KIDS WHO WERE SPRAYED GO
ON TO DEVELOP NON HODGKINS
LYMPHOMA WHEN THE HIGHEST
CANCERS IN OF PEOPLE TODAY AS
WELL AS YOUR DOG. THEN NOBODY IS
GOING TO BE ABLE TO LOOK AT THIS
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THESE
CANCERS AND.
EARLIER SPRING AND NOBODY'S
LOOKING AT THAT DATA BETWEEN
PREVIOUS PRAYING AND PRESENT.
SO THERE IS NOTHING GOING ON
THERE.
THE WE WERE BEFORE THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE THEY MADE
REGARDING LEAST TOXIC.
PESTICIDES TO BE USED IN
CHILDREN'S SCHOOLS AND WE HAVE
PUT FORWARD TO THIS COMMITTEES
LEAST TOXIC EXPERT ON PESTICIDES
THAT CAN BE USE THAT HAVE BEEN
USED SUCCESSFULLY IN IRVINE
COUNTY. WAS A TREMENDOUS OF
REDUCTION IN COSTS AND WATER
USAGE UP TO TWENTY PERCENT AND
BEAUTIFUL GREEN FIELDS DELIVER
IT I'M I APOLOGIZE OF
INTERRUPTING YOU BUT IT THAT
THE.
COMMITTEE POLICY IS TO WITNESSES
TWO MINUTES EACH ARM IF YOU'D
LIKE TO GIVE YOUR TIME TO HER
SHE'S WELCOME TO GO ON FOR
ANOTHER TWO MINUTES IF NOT.
PERHAPS YOU CAN JUST CLOSE AND
THEN THE NEXT WITNESS COULD TELL
ALLOW ME TO CLOSE AND AND I.
UP IS TO BE QUICK OKAY SO WHAT
I'M ASKING THIS COMMITTEE AND
REGARDING THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEES OUR RECOMMENDATION
FOR VALUE TO PROCESS THEY DON'T
HAVE ANY HEALTH PROVIDERS
LOOKING AT THIS EVALUATION SO
THERE'S NOBODY REALLY MONITORING
THE HEALTH OF CHILDREN. AND THE
EFFECT OF CHEMICAL SPRAYING AND
HEALTH EFFECTS OF A KID GETS AN
ASTHMA ATTACK AFTER SPRAY NO
ONE'S PUTTING THOSE PIECES
TOGETHER I CAN ASSURE YOU.
PEDIATRICIANS ARE ALSO NOT
LOOKING AT THE EFFECT OF
ENVIRONMENTAL TOXICANTS AND
HEALTH AND ARE NOT TRAINED TO DO
SO NOR ARE THEY DOING ANY
LABORATORY TESTING ON THIS AS
WELL.
SO I COME TO THIS COMMITTEE WITH
THE REQUEST HERE'S THE ASK THAT
THIS COMMITTEE HELP ME TO DO MY
JOB TO TAKE CARE OF CHILDREN ON
THE FRONTLINE. THAT'S MY ASK
WHETHER YOU CAN HELP ME DO MY
JOB.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN THE NEXT
WITNESS YOU HAVE ABOUT A MINUTE
AND HALF.
I'M DIANE EVERYDAY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA GUILD WARS STATEWIDE.
ORGANIZATION A LOT OF.
AGRICULTURE FOCUS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL FOCUS WERE
FRATERNAL GROUPS.
AND WE SUPPORT STRONGLY OF THE
MISSION OF ASSEMBLYMAN
MURATSUCHI IN THIS BILL TO
REDUCE EXPOSURE OF CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA TO PESTICIDES. WE WE
KNOW OF.
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE CHILDREN
THAT ARE EXPOSED WE HAVE FRIENDS
THAT HAVE CHILDREN THAT ARE
EXPOSED WE KNOW THAT THERE IS
THE SCIENCE IT EXISTS IN
DEMONSTRATED NONTOXIC IRVINE. AS
A DUCT PARA MENTIONED
TO TREAT.
A PEST PROBLEMS WITH NONTOXIC
INTERVENTIONS
WE ASK FOR A LEAST TOXIC FIRST
POLICY.
FOR OF THE A HEALTHY SCHOOLS ACT
PROVISIONS RELATED TO INTEGRATED
PEST MANAGEMENT THAT WOULD HELP.
AND WE HOPE THE COMMITTEE WOULD
MAKE SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE A.
OF AT LEAST A PARTIAL FIX WE
WILL I KNOW YOU WANT INTERMENT
INCREMENTAL. BUT WE DO SOMETHING
TO HELP CHILDREN AND REDUCE
THEIR EXPOSURE TO CHILDREN TO
PESTICIDES
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WHO WANTS TO COME
FOREIGN SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL PLEASE COME FORWARD STEP ON
UP TO THE MICROPHONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANA GORMAN
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA HEALTH
COALITION ADVOCACY.
IN FULL SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND
ALSO ENCOURAGE YOU TO ADOPT.
THE AMENDMENTS OFFERED BY
CALIFORNIA KILLED THINK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
NO.
OKAY IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS NICKEL
COMMUNITY ON BEHALF OF THE
HOUSEHOLD AND COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION OUT WHILE
WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN ON ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION WHICH A LIMITED THIS
BILL THAT WOULD OF I'M FULLY UP
BEYOND PESTICIDE USE AYE IN IN
SCHOOLS WITH SOME. AYE
EXCEPTIONS WE DO STILL BELIEVE
THAT THE CURRENT BILL IS
UNNECESSARY ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION IN THE
UNITED STATES ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY.
PERFORMS A THOROUGH REVIEW OF
THESE PRODUCTS BEFORE THEY'RE
REGISTERED AND ALLOWED TO BE
USED IN THE STATE.
AND THEY ALSO ALWAYS HAVE THE
ABILITY TO A REVIEW AND EVALUATE
THESE PRODUCTS CONTINUOUSLY AND
IF THEY FIND THAT THERE'S ANY
POTENTIAL FOR HARM AYE THEY CAN.
.
I APPLY RESTRICTIONS UP MORE
COMPLETELY BEYOND THESE PRODUCTS
SO.
THE AUTHORITIES ALREADY THERE
IDEA ALSO AM CONCERNED IT MIGHT
NOT BE THE MOST EFFICIENT USE OF
RESOURCES.
TO REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT TO
EVALUATE ALL OF THESE.
PRODUCT THERE'S AN AND NUMBER
OF PRODUCTS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
ALLOWED TO BE USED IN OUR
SCHOOLS AND RECOMMEND TO THE
LEGISLATURE WHAT SHOULD BE
BANNED WHEN THEY ALREADY HAVE
THAT AUTHORITY SO. I WE ARE
NEUTRAL ON THE ASPECT OF THE
BILL THAT.
DIRECT DPR TO A VALUE WITH HOW
THE HEALTHY SCHOOLS ACT IS
WORKING ON AND WE DO SUPPORT
INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT.
.
STATE OF THINKING.
THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL WHO
WANTS TO COME FORWARD.
NOPE.
OKAY THEN WE WILL BRING IN
APPEAR TO THE DIETS FOR.
COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
SECOND.
OKAY NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
WHAT I HAVE A COUPLE.
.
SO.
DOESN'T DP ARE ALREADY HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO BAN CERTAIN
PESTICIDES.
WELL WE WANTED TO SPECIFICALLY.
HAVE THE DP OUR REVIEW THAT THAT
SIDE SAID.
AS TO THE.
POTENTIAL HEALTH IMPACTS RATE
CHILDREN IN SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
ARM IN ORIGINALLY.
.
MY BILL AS INDICATED BY THE
OPPOSITION WAS TO BAN ALL.
PESTICIDES ADD TO THE SCHOOLS
ARM.
.
GIVEN THAT.
IT FOR EXAMPLE.
DOG LIFE STATE A ONE OF THE
MOST. CONTROVERSIAL AND COMMONLY
USED HERBICIDES.
COMMONLY KNOWN AS ROUNDUP.
HAS NOT BEEN BANNED BY.
.
THE DEPARTMENT.
SO WE WANTED TO.
PROVIDE DATA.
.
FURTHER AMMUNITION TO THE
DEPARTMENT TO.
SPECIFICALLY EVALUATE.
POTENTIAL HEALTH IMPACTS AND AND
HOW.
THE IPM.
PROGRAMS ARE BEING.
APPLIED WHETHER THEY ARE IN FACT
BEING APPLIED AT AT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
.
TO.
GIVE US MORE INFORMATION NOW ON
HOW WE'RE DOING AND TO MAKE A
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS AS TO
WHETHER CLOCK STATE OR ANY OTHER
PET SITE SHOULD BE BANNED.
SO I GUESS IT'S IT'S TWO PARTS
ONE IS TO EVALUATE.
ON THE EFFECTS OF LEGISLATION
WAS PREVIOUSLY PASSED RIGHT WITH
THAT INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT
PLAN. AND THEN THE SECOND PART
WOULD BE TO IDENTIFY WHICH
PESTICIDES.
.
THEY THINK SHOULD BE BANNED IN
RATHER THAN DOING THAT
THEMSELVES THEY WOULD BRING IT
TO THE LEGISLATURE. TO.
THAT'S ARKWRIGHT IT WOULD ADD
THAT THIS BILL CALLS FOR THE DPR
TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE AS TO WHETHER ONE OR
MORE. PESTICIDES SHOULD BE TODAY
SO.
HERE'S MY CONCERN WITH THIS
BILL BECAUSE RIGHT I HAVE KIDS
AT SCHOOL TOO SO.
I'D DEFINITELY SHARE THE
CONCERN OF THEM GOING TO SCHOOL
AND PLAYING IN THE FIELD. MY
BOYS RIGHT NOW ARE PLAYING FLAG
FOOTBALL IN P. E. AND THEY'RE
ALL OVER THE PLACE IN THE GRASS.
.
SO I GET IT YOU KNOW YOU KNOW
WHAT YOUR KIDS COMING HOME WITH
ANY STORE SORTS OF REACTIONS
NAM.
BUT MY CONCERN IS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS BEING ASKED TO
STEP IN AND DO THE JOB OF DP ARE
WHICH IS SUPPOSED TO BE. THAT
THEY IDENTIFY THEM THE
PESTICIDES OR CHEMICALS THAT
SHOULD BE BANNED BECAUSE THEN I
FEEL.
THAT WE'RE GOING TO GET ON THE
ROAD OF.
.
THE LEGISLATURE BEING LOBBIED TO
TO BAN THIS TO ALLOW THAT WHICH
CAN GET VERY MESSY AND REALLY
SHOULDN'T. BE SOMETHING THAT WE
ARE DECIDING ON THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE DP ARE GREAT IS WE PUT IT
IN THEIR HANDS AND SAY OKAY THIS
IS YOUR JOB YOUR YOUR
RESPONSIBILITIES. AND YOU NEED
NOT THEY'RE NOT DOING THAT THEN
PERHAPS WE NEED TO RE EVALUATE.
HOW THEY'RE DOING THEIR JOB OR
WHAT AUTHORITY THEY HAVE BUT
THAT'S MY CONCERN?
WHICH AND I'M SURE YOU
UNDERSTAND IT'S IN WHERE WE
STEPPING OVER THE LINE.
.
IN AND WHAT THE LEGISLATURE'S
AUTHORITY.
SHOULD BE IN CASES LIKE THIS.
WELL AND AND IN RESPONSE AYE
YEAH AYE.
HERE WHICH SANG OF I I THINK
IT'S A.
YOU KNOW IT IT WOULD BE. I
BELIEVE A MORE THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH IF THE.
THE SCIENTISTS AND EXPERTS AT
THE DPR MAKE THE RECOMMENDATIONS
AND THEN WE CAN DECIDE.
WHETHER IN FACT HIM IS HE TAKE
THE NEXT STEP OF OF BANNING THE
PEST SIDE.
AND.
.
YOU KNOW THE VIEW WHEN I HAVE
KIDS PLAYING ON THESE FIELDS I I
THINK IT'S NOT JUST.
VIA THE THE SKINNER AYE
IRRITATIONS THAT WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT BUT WHAT YOU DON'T LIKE
LIKE TO SAY.
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
HAS A.
DESIGNATED AS A.
AS THE COURT CARCINOGEN.
AND.
WE DON'T WANT. OUR KIDS TO BE
EXPOSED TO CANCER CAUSING
CHEMICALS AND SO I THINK THIS IS
A RESPONSIBLE LOWER. I EFFORT TO
TO FIRST TO.
TAKE BEYOND THAT TO HAVE THE DPR
EVALUATE.
.
YOU KNOW THE STATUS OF A PATH
SIDE MANAGEMENT AT OUR SCHOOLS
AND AND AND TO DO.
PACIFIC WE MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS
SO THAT WE CAN DECIDE WHETHER TO
TAKE ACTION ON.
HAVE YOU BY ANY CHANCE HAD ANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH ANYONE IT DPR
ABOUT THE FACT THAT.
THERE ARE SOME PESTICIDES DID
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE AND OTHER
PARENTS HAVE CONCERNS WITH THAT
ARE STILL ON THE LIST. OF.
.
USES THAT ARE ALLOWED.
I BUT I HAVE NOT TO HAD DIRECT
CONVERSATIONS I KNOW MY STAFF
HAS BUT TO.
AGAIN THERE THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW THE P. R. TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO US AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT. A WE SHOULD BE
CONSIDERING BANNING THOSE
SPECIFIES THAT YOU'RE FOR INTO.
OKAY WELL IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU ARE
FRUSTRATED WITH DP OURS LACK OF.
ACTION.
M. MIGHT BE A WAY YOU DON'T HAVE
TO YOU KNOW.
SAY THAT YOURSELF WHICH IS HOW I
SEE IT BUT MIGHT BE. THE
APPROPRIATE WAY TO CATEGORIZE
IT.
I JUST.
I AGREE WITH. WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
THAT WE SHOULD BE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE USE OF SOME OF THESE
CHEMICALS MY PROBLEM IS?
PUTTING IT IN THE LEGISLATURE'S
HANDS I THINK THERE SHOULD BE
MORE PUT PRESSURE PLOT APPLIED
TO DPR. TO DO WHAT THEY HAVE
BEEN TASKED WITH DOING RATHER
THEY AND.
.
KEEP THEM IN PLACE BUT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO TAKE ON THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY THERE'S NO POINT
HAVING THEM THERE THAT ARE GOING
TO DO THEIR JOB. SELL I THINK
I'M GONNA HAVE TO.
.
ABSTAINED FROM VOTING ON THIS
ONE AND MAYBE YOU KNOW THERE ARE
SOME CHANGES MADE ALONG THE WAY.
WERE ACT OR I COULD LOOK DOWN
THE ROAD SUPPORT IT BUT ALBUM.
THIS JUST CAUSES ME SOME CONCERN
WITH THE WITH THE PROCESS NOT
THE CONCEPT THAT THE PROCESS
ALTHOUGH. PUMP I THINK WE'D A
MOTION AND A SECOND MISTER
CHAIRMAN DID YOU HAVE A CLOSING
COMMENT YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
YES WELL WHY DON'T YOU. DO YOU
WANT TO CLOSE FIRST
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR. OKAY ARM
FIRST OF ALL THERE'S NOTHING
THAT WOULD STOP DPR FROM
TOMORROW BANNING SOMETHING AND
THERE'S NOTHING IN THE BILL THAT
WOULD CHANGE THAT.
SO.
IT.
ASK DERIVE OF.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
RATE SO.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND TAKE ROLE.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER NINE.
AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTEEN WERE AT
SOCHI THE MOTION AS DO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ.
NOT NOT VOTING.
ARAMBULA.
BROKE.
BROUGH NOT VOTING.
BLOOM.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
WHAT A TO G. I?
THREE OF THREE VOTES WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN OKAY SO THAT THAT.
VOTE ON CALL RIGHT NOW UNTIL WE
MISTER BLOOM SHOWS THAT I'M
THINKING THIS MURATSUCHI DO WE
HAVE.
ANYONE KNOWS.
CHOOSE HERE.
THERE IS ALL CAN MISTER CHIU.
OKAY SO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB TWO
FIVE ZERO ONE MISTER CHIU
WELCOME.
SACRAMENTO AND CHAIR.
AND HOPE FOR.
CHAIR WILL GET HIS VOICE BACK
SOON.
OF OUR I WANT TO THANK THE.
TO COMMITTEE STAFF FLOOR
YOURSELF ANNOUNCES ITSELF IS
FILLED.
AB TWENTY FIVE ALL ONE WORD
INCREASE* TO CLEAN DRINKING
WATER. BY EXPANDING THE STATE
WATER BOARD TO AUTHORITY TO
REQUIRE A CONSOLIDATION OF.
SMALL WATER SYSTEMS
WHICH LAST AND FIFTEEN
CONNECTIONS SO I'M TALKING ABOUT
REALLY REALLY SMALL. WATER
SYSTEMS THEY ARE A CONSISTENTLY
EXPERIENCE IN POOR WATER
QUALITY.
IT IS HARD TO BELIEVE THAT THERE
ARE ABOUT ONE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS ARE STILL LACKING
OVER* TO SAVE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER.
EVEN. WITH THIS STATE'S ONGOING
EFFORT AND CURRENT LAW ALREADY
ALLOW THE WATER BOARD TO REQUIRE
THE CONSOLIDATION. AND EXTENSION
OF SERVICES TO WATER SYSTEM DATA
GOOD GUY ARE STRUGGLING TO
PROVIDE CLEAN DRINKING WATER.
THIS BILL FOCUS UNDER RELEASED
SMALL WATER SYSTEM THERE ARE
OFTEN.
OVERLOOKED BOOKED ARE THE MOST
VULNERABLE.
A LOT OF THOSE WATER SUSPEND OUR
NEXT TO LARGE.
NEXT DOOR TO A LARGE MUCH
LARGER WATER SYSTEM THAT CAN
EASILY AS SOON DOES FEW. OF
CUSTOMERS
M. MY BILL WILL ALLOW THIS TO
HAPPEN PUSHED UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE. GOOD THIS STATE WILL HELP
ADEQUATE FUNDING PRO PRIOR TO A
REQUIRING IN SUCH CONSOLIDATIONS
SO OF A WOULD NOT BE A WHO A
COST BURDEN FOR THE. LARGER
WATER SYSTEMS TO ACQUIRE DOES
THE HERBS A SMALL WATER SYSTEM
AND HERE WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. IS PHOEBE
STEVEN WAS PHILIP LEADERSHIP
CONSOLE FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND THEN FRANCISCO MENDEZ
WHO CAN SPEAK MORE ON HIS OWN
EXPERIENCE WORKING DIRECTLY WITH
THE A IMPACTED COMMUNITY MEMBERS
SO WAS THAT. WE MEET THE LOWER.
HOPEFULLY WE WILL NOT UNTIL
WITNESSING RIGHT WHEN WE HAVE
TWO MINUTES FOR EACH OF YOU SO
WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO FIRST.
RENTAL WELL HE'S GOING TO BE FOR
US LIVES IN BUSINESS AND PIN AND
I MEAN THEY DON'T BELIEVE ME
NOTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND THAT WILL MY NAME IS
FRANCISCO AMEND THIS I BELIEVE
IN FRESNO.
AND I HAVE ISSUES ON PROGRAMS
ALL MY LIFE.
ALMOST ALL MY LIFE ABOUT WATER
PROBLEMS.
I USED TO WORK AT THAT VERY FARM
ON THE BOYS NEVER GIVE US YOU
KNOW WATER FOR DRINK WE HAVE
TUTORING FROM THAT WELL NEAR
CARE.
AND I AM LUCKY NOW
THAT.
I HAVE CLEAN WATER I OWN MY OWN
HOUSE I LIVE IN FRESNO.
BOUGHT HOUSE SENSE ON FAMILIES
THOUGH NOT HAVE.
THEY LUCKY THAT I AM.
TWO HUNDRED CAN WATER.
BECAUSE SO THEY ARE LEAVING
OUTSIDE THE CD ON SO MANY
FAMILIES ARE HAVING OILS.
PULLING UP THE WATER
CONTAMINATED WITH CHEMICALS.
AND I I'M HERE.
FOR YOUR SUPPORT TO HELP THESE
BUILT THE BUS PLEASE.
THANKS FRANCISCO IN AND GOOD
AFTERNOON PVC OR LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY JUST AND TO ADD A
FEW MORE DETAILS TO TO A
FRANCISCO DISCUSSED.
JUST OUTSIDE THE CITY OF FRESNO
THERE'S MANY MANY COMMUNITY IS
DEPENDENT ON DOMESTIC WELLS.
WITH WITH YOU EITHER TESTED IT
LEVELS OF NITRATE ANTI CP AND
OTHER CONTAMINANTS OR THEY'RE
NOT TESTED BECAUSE OF UNDER TECH
BECAUSE MANY SMALL SYSTEMS IN
THE MASSIVE WALLS AREN'T TESTED.
OMINOUS NOT JUST THE CITY OF
FRESNO IT'S HUNDREDS OF
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
ITS TOMBSTONE TERRITORY JUST
OUTSIDE THE SANGER IT'S THE AREA
OUTSIDE OF THE COMMUNITY SERVICE
DISTRICT OF DEL HIGH. AND AGAIN
THE CONTAMINANTS VARY BUT THE
SITUATIONS DON'T AND THAT THERE
ARE THEM THE. SOME OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS JUST
WITH AND WITHIN A MILE SOMETIMES
FIVE HUNDRED FEET SOMETIMES.
TWENTY FEET
OF A SERVICE LINES THAT PROVIDE
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER AND THIS BILL SIMPLY
IMPROVES UPON A A TOOL THAT THE
STATE ALREADY HAS. TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE MOST VULNERABLE AMONG
US A SAFE DRINKING WATER THANKS
SO MUCH.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE HE WANTS TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL NAME
ORGANIZATION ONLY PLEASE.
A MORENO VIA CIRCLE CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT.
YET OF US GIVE THEM HALF A
CALIFORNIA RAMPS JUSTICE
ALLIANCES SUPPORT OF.
DEBBIE YOURS ON BEHALF OF
CLEARWATER CENTER AND SUPPORT.
BRIAN AGAINST ON BEHALF OF THE
RURAL COMMUNITY ASSISTANCE
CORPORATION AND SELF HELP
ENTERPRISES IN SUPPORT.
IT AFTERNOON MATTHEW BAKER WITH
PLANNING CONSERVATION LEAGUE WE
HAVEN'T OFFICIALLY WEIGHT IN ON
THIS BILL BUT WE DO SUPPORT ITS
INTENT.
OKAY.
NOW ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL OF WOULD YOU COME
FORWARD PLEASE TESTIMONY IS
LIMITED TO TWO MINUTES.
TWO WITNESSES EACH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS AND CAN
UNITS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES WHEN I THINK THE AUTHOR
AND HIS. STAFF HAVE BEEN VERY
GENEROUS ONE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
IF LANGUAGE IS BEING DELETED
FROM EXISTING LAW THAT ALLOWS
WATER AGENCIES TO RECOVER COSTS.
WE THINK THAT THE STATE WATER
BOARD SHOULD BE STRONGER
LANGUAGE REQUIRING THEM TO COVER
THE COSTS OF CONSOLIDATIONS
THAT'S REALLY ARE. OUR PRIMARY
CONCERN.
SO YOU ARE AT OPPOSE OR ARE WE
ARE POSING AS AMENDED RIGHT NOW
WE JUST WANT TO SEIZE
STRONGER LANGUAGE.
OKAY AROUND BECAUSE RICK.
OKAY CAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SHORTNESS WITNESS TESTIMONY TO
HIM.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE WHO WANTS
TO TEST BY AN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL PLEASE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE.
NO ONE OKAY I'VE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM THE DIET. MISTER
BRO.
THINKING I SHARE MR CHIU THANKS
FOR BRINGING THIS. THIS BILL
FORWARD.
A.
I'M ALL FOR CONSOLIDATION BUT I
THINK FOR DIFFERENT REASONS.
.
YOU KNOW IN MY I'VE TEN
COMMUNITIES IN MY DISTRICT I
THINK WE HAVE SIX WATER
DISTRICTS.
SIX BOARDS YOU KNOW ALL THAT.
AND ESSENTIALLY THERE JUST
MIDDLEMAN ABOUT DELIVERING A
SERVICE FOR ASSUME THAT OR.
ORANGE COUNTY WATER DISTRICT
SOMETHIN.
SO I'M ALL FOR CONSOLIDATION I
THINK MY CONCERN IS.
ONE OF MY DISTRICTS.
IS SAN JUAN CAPISTRANO TO
CITIES AND WE CAPS ON HAS OUR
OWN WATER DISTRICT AND.
IT'S IT'S GOT SOME AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND.
IT'S
CONSIDER BY THE OTHER DISTRICT
DOESN'T AS A BAD ASSET. LA WITH
DEBT AND THINGS LIKE THAT AND BE
A LOT COSTLY TO FOUND IMPROVE
THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND GET UP
TO.
GET UP TO SPEED HOW WOULD YOU
ADDRESS IF THERE WAS A
CONSOLIDATION.
AND IN ANOTHER AGENCY TOOK OVER
THIS THIS
BAD ASSET THAT HAS CONTAMINATED
WATER AND MAYBE LEAKING PIPES
AND THINGS
WHAT WHAT HOW WOULD THE COST BE.
BE DELIBERATED THROUGH THAT
PROCESS.
THAT WERE BROUGHT BACK TO COOK
GOOD QUESTION BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING. OF THE MOON I
HOPE WE ALL OF IF I'M WRONG.
THAT THE STATE TO ACTUALLY HOUSE
OF FUNDING AVAILABLE. TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE AND HOW I WANT TO GO
BACK TO THIS BILL WAS FREELY
FOCUS ON THOSE VERY VERY SMALL
WATER DISTRICT. FIFTEEN OR
CONNECTORS OR LAST OKAY YOU KNOW
SO WE'RE GONNA MAKE SURE THAT.
NOW TO BE ABLE TO.
BECOME A PART OF THAT BIGGER
WATER SYSTEM TO FOR TO ADDRESS
THE TO THIS THE. WATER QUALITY.
KAY.
WELL THANKS FOR THAT
CLARIFICATION OPPRESSION.
ANYONE ELSE ON THE COMMITTEE
WITH A QUESTION OR COMMENT
.
LEARN ALUM. HUNCHED CLOSE.
THERE
WHEN YOU CHIU CLOSE VOTE THANK
YOU ARGUE THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A BIBLE.
.
I HAVE A QUESTION NO I'M SORRY
BEFORE WE BEFORE WE JUST MOVE
ON.
.
BECAUSE ASSEMBLYMAN BRO AND I
SHOULD YOU KNOW SHARE.
.
THE SAME VIEWPOINT IS FOR IS
BEING ABLE TO CONSOLIDATE THESE
BUT THE QUESTION IS IS THERE ANY
GUARANTEE THAT IT WON'T BE THE
RATE PAYERS WHO HAVE TO ASSUME
THE COST.
IF THERE'S A GUARANTEED THAT.
YOU DON'T THAT IT'S COMING FROM.
GRANT FUNDS BOND FUNDS STATE
WHEREVER IT'S COMING FROM.
IT'S JUST IS THERE A GUARANTEE
THAT IT'S NOT AND I AM FROM
HARRY. I BELIEVE TO DAY I I'M
SURE THERE IS A CURRENT THAT THE
STATE REVOLVING FUND.
AND IF BROWN'S A THE BOND OF
PROCEEDS PROPOSITION ONE COULD
ALSO A BLUE COVER SOME OF THE
COST. AND I'M SURE THE
PROPOSITION SIXTY A CURRENTLY ON
THE BALLOT IT WILL IT COULD BE A
ANOTHER POTENTIAL A FUNDING
SOURCE.
SO THERE OF SOME A REVOLVING
FUND AVAILABLE TODAY. OKAY I'M
WOULD THEIR REPRESENTATIVE FROM
AQUA COME BACK UP HERE. JUSTIN.
ALSO PROVIDER.
.
RESPONSE TO THE.
BOB I JUST LIKE TO POINT OUT
AGAIN THIS IS FOR CONNECTIONS A
FIFTEEN OR LESS.
YEAH.
SO FROM FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
CURRENT LAW DOES ALLOW A WATER
SYSTEM TO. RECOVER COSTS THROUGH
THE RATEPAYERS OF CHARGING.
WITH THE RATEPAYERS THAT WERE
SUBSUMED AND IN THIS NEW SYSTEM
CHARGING THEM FOR THE COST OF
CONSOLIDATION THIS BILL WOULD
PROHIBIT THAT.
AND SO WHAT WE WANT TO ENSURE IS
THAT IF THE STATE WATER BOARD
DOES INDEED HAVE FUNDING FOR
THIS THAT THEY DO PAY FOR THAT.
AND IT'S NOT THE WATER SYSTEM
HAS TO JUST ABSORB IT SO. FOR US
I DO UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
SOME FUN THERE SOME FUNDS
AVAILABLE FOR THIS.
.
THERE HAVE BEEN MANY
CONSOLIDATIONS THERE HAVE BEEN
MANDATED BY THE WATER BOARD I
THINK BECAUSE FUNDING HAS BEEN
DIFFICULT TO COME BY. SO.
FOR US AT LEAST WE WANT SOME
STRONG LANGUAGE IN THAT IT SAYS
THE STATE WATER BOARD SHALL.
COVER THE COSTS OF
CONSOLIDATION.
AND IS THERE ANY INTENTION ON
YOUR PART MISTER CHIU TO ARAB
LANGUAGE LIKE THAT OR PERHAPS
AND GOOD TO BAYLISS IS AT THE
STATE'S GOOD NOW. OF WOODEN NAM
MANDATE THE CONSOLIDATION.
WATER BOY Y. NOW MANDATED TO
CONSOLIDATION ALASKA OR TO
ADEQUATE FUNDING SOLD IT WOULD
DO HOW BIRD.
TAKE THAT APPROACH TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE FUNDING TO STARE.
BILL BEFORE THE WAR CAN MANDATE
DOSA CONSOLIDATIONS SO IS YOUR
YOUR PROTECTOR MY.
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT I'M I I THINK.
I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE THIS OUT.
I THINK THAT AQUA HAS GOOD
REASONS FOR ASKING FOR STRONGER
LANGUAGE AND I WOULD SUGGEST YOU
DO THAT.
ARE AT THIS TIME AYE URGENT AYE
VOTE SO WE CAN MOVE THE BILL
FORWARD WHICH I THINK IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
YOU.
OKAY THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED SO WE WANT TO CALL THE
ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM SIX AB TWENTY FIVE
OH ONE CHIU THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
QUIRK I
QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ AYE MELINDA'S
AYE.
ARAMBULA.
BROKE.
BROUGH AYE.
BLOOM.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
WHAT A TO CHEAT?
WELL THAT'S WHAT SHE AYE.
FIVE.
ANSWERS TO CONGRATULATE YOU.
I'M NEED.
OUR ARMED.
I'M NOT I'M GONNA GO PRESENTED
ANOTHER COMMITTEE.
I SINCE WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH FOR
THIS IS PROBABLY GOOD TIME FOR
ME TO GO.
I SHALL RETURN TO CHAIRMAN WILL
LAST HOPEFULLY BE DONE BY THE
TIME WE GET BACK AND.
AND WE LOSE.
SOME
FIVE THREE EIGHTHS.
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE GUY HAD
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TODAY I
AM HERE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY EIGHT WHICH
ALLOWS THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD.
TO DEVELOP FINANCIAL CAPABILITY
ASSESSMENT GUIDELINES TO BETTER
ASSIST LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WHEN
DEVELOPING STORM WATER PERMITS.
UNDER EXISTING FEDERAL LAW THE
CLEAN WATER ACT REGULATES
DISCHARGES OF POLLUTANTS INTO
THE WATER OF THE UNITED STATES
AND REGULATES QUALITY STANDARDS
FOR SURFACE WATER WHILE TAKING
FINANCIAL CAPABILITY INTO
ACCOUNT.
UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW THE PORTER
COLOGNE. A WATER QUALITY ACT
PROHIBITS THE DISCHARGE OF
POLLUTANTS A TO SURFACE WATER
UNLESS THE DISCHARGE OBTAINS A
PERMIT FROM THE STATE WATER
BOARD.
I MISS FOR STORM WATER PERMITS
ARE CRITICAL FOR PROTECTING
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT BUT THEY CAN ALSO BE
CHALLENGING AND COSTLY TO
IMPLEMENT.
ALTHOUGH CITIES AND COUNTIES ARE
DEVELOPING THEIR STORMWATER
POLLUTANT SCHEDULES MANY REMAIN
IN NEED.
OF GUIDANCE AND TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE IN ORDER TO DEVELOP
ADEQUATE CONSISTENT AND COST ARE
INFORMED PERMITS.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE AUDITOR MARCH FIRST TWENTY
EIGHTEEN REPORT THEIR VARIOUS
FINDINGS INDICATING THAT THE
STATE WATER BOARD AND REGIONAL
WHAT APPROACH BLACK. CONSISTENT
INFORMATION ON COSTS THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS INCUR IN COMPLYING
WITH THE STORM WATER
REQUIREMENTS
THE AUDITOR ALSO FOUND THAT THE
STATE WATER BOARD HAS NOT
ADEQUATELY CONSIDERED THE COST
THAT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WOULD
INCUR IN ORDER TO COMPLY WITH.
REQUIREMENTS.
AND THAT THE STATE WATER BOARD
HAS NOT PROVIDED GUIDANCE TO
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ON HOW TO
TRACK AND REPORT STORM WATER
MANAGEMENT.
EXPENDITURES MY BILL AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT ADDRESSES
THESE ISSUES BY CALLING ON THE
STATE WATER BOARD TO DEVELOP
FINANCIAL CAPABILITY ASSESSMENT
GUIDELINES. THAT WILL PROVIDE
GUIDANCE TO THE LA REGIONAL
WATER BOARD WHEN HELPING LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS DEVELOP STORMWATER
PERMITS.
THIS BILL IS A PILOT PROJECT TO
ASSESS.
IF A FINANCIAL CAPABILITY
ANNOUNCES CAN BE EFFECTIVE.
EFFECTIVELY USED TO HELP
ADDITIONAL CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPALITIES
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE POOR SUGGEST BUT
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS WHICH I
ACCEPT.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT I
HAVE TWO WITNESSES.
ERIC WOLFE ON BEHALF OF THE
THANK YOU FOR VALLEY COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS AND DIANA MY MOOD
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THIS I GIVE
ABOUT THE COUNCIL GOVERNMENT'S.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF WHO WOULD
LIKE TO GO FIRST OF BEGIN IRATE
GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND.
HONORABLE COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M
ERIC WHAT THE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS ARE
REPRESENTING THIRTY CITIES IN
OVER TWO MILLION RESIDENTS IN
THE LA AREA.
AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY EIGHT IS
INTENDED TO AFFORD FLEXIBILITY
TO EXTEND THE TIMELINE FOR
COMPLIANCE.
WITH STORMWATER PERMITS BASED ON
TO SEE A CITIES DEMONSTRATED
FINANCIAL NEED SO THAT'S WHAT
THIS IS ABOUT THAT'S WHAT I SEE
IS ABOUT. MANY LA COUNTY CITIES
FACE STORMWATER COMPLIANCE
ESTIMATES EXCEED SEVERAL HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS.
THESE HIGH COSTS ARE SPECIALLY
CHALLENGING FOR THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMITTEES WITHIN
THE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY.
THOSE COMMITTEES OUR ALREADY
STRUGGLE TO PROVIDE BASIC
MUNICIPAL SERVICES.
AND CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SINGLE
VALLEY CITIES ARE NOT ALONE IN
FACING THESE EXTRAORDINARY
COSTS.
WELL THIS IS A PROBLEM THAT'S
REPEATED ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND IN RESPONSE TO THIS
CHALLENGE THE EPA IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN RELEASED.
FINANCIAL CAPABILITY ASSESSMENT
FRAMEWORK SO THE EPA HAS FCA
GUIDELINES.
.
IF IT IS A LITTLE BIT
COMPLICATED BUT THEIR STAFF IS
DESCRIBED IT AS PROVIDING
REGULATORS WITH THE FLEXIBILITY
TO CONSIDER. A MUNICIPAL PERMIT
TEASE ABILITY TO PAY FOR AND
DELIVER WATER SERVICES.
IT CONSIDERS VARIOUS MEASURES
SUCH AS HOUSE A HOUSEHOLDS
ABILITY TO PAY FOR THE TOTALITY.
OF WATER RELATED COSTS.
AS WELL AS THE COMMUNITIES
FINANCIAL ABILITY TO DELIVER
SERVICES BASED ON SEVERAL
FACTORS
SUCH AS THEIR DEBT BURDEN THEIR
DEMOGRAPHICS AND SOME OTHER
CHARACTERISTICS.
REGARDING THE HOUSEHOLD COSTS.
NOW THE EPA RECOMMENDS CAPPING
WATER RELATED EXPENSES THAT THE
TOTAL WATER RELATED EXPENSES AT
FOR A HALF PERCENT.
OF MEDIAN HOUSEHOLD INCOME.
AND THAT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THE US
CONFERENCE OF MAYORS.
CONDUCTED A STUDY AND FOUND
THAT ALMOST HALF OF SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY CITIES HAVE SOME
RESIDENTS THAT ARE PAYING MORE.
THAN THAT FOREIGN A HALF PERCENT
MHI FOR THEIR WATER AND IN SOME
CITIES IT WAS OVER TWENTY
PERCENT OF RESIDENTS THAT PAY
MORE THAN THAT SO.
SO A FIFTY THEIR POPULATION.
AND THIS IS JUST ONE REASON THAT
HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED FOR AB
TWENTY FIVE.
THIRTY EIGHT.
FOR THE STATE WATER BOARD TO
ESTABLISH FCA GUIDELINES AND TO
DEVELOP AN UNDERSTANDING OF THE
COSTS A MUNICIPALITIES BOTH
HOUSEHOLDS AND CITIES.
FOR WATER RELATED COSTS.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE STATE
BOARD AND THE LA REACH REPORTER
PARTICULAR USE THOSE GUIDELINES
IN THIS PILOT PROJECT.
COUNCIL MEMBER MAHMOUD WILL
FOLLOW WITH SOME ADDITIONAL AND
THOUGHTS ABOUT IF CA AND HOW CAN
HELP CITIES. BUT I SUBMIT THAT
AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
OFFERS A COMMON SENSE APPROACH.
TO THE HIGH ESTIMATED COST OF
THE MESS FOR PERMIT COMPLIANCE.
AND WILL BE PARTICULARLY HELPFUL
TO DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WHO
ARE ALREADY STRUGGLING.
TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO THEIR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY YOU
ARE OVER YOUR TIME LIMIT BUT
COUNSELING MAHMOUD WOULD YOU
WANT TO AND JUMP IN THEIR GIVE
YOUR TESTIMONY PLEASE I SURE
WOULD THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO PRESENT TESTIMONY I AM I AM
I NOT ONLY REPRESENT MY CITY OF
SOUTH PASADENA BUT I'M ALSO
CHAIR OF THE WATER POLICY
COMMITTEE AT THE SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY CALLED. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI FOR
INITIATING YOUR REQUEST TO THE
STATE AUDITOR IT CONFIRMS WHAT
WE HAVE BEEN SAYING AS CITIES
FOR SEVERAL YEARS BAD IS THAT
REGIONAL BOARDS ARE NOT
CONSIDERING THE COST OF
COMPLIANCE.
AND BAT.
THERE'S NO ESTABLISHED METRICS
BY WHICH TO TRACK STORM WATER
COST AND HOW CAN THE STATE
RESPONSIBLY ADDRESS AND IMPOSE.
STORM WATER QUALITY PERMITS
WITHOUT KNOWING THE COST THIS IS
PARTICULARLY TRUE BECAUSE STORM
WATER IS AN ORPHAN UTILITY.
USUALLY CITIES HAVE NO OTHER
SOURCE OF FUNDS.
TO ADDRESS THEIR STORM WATER
COMPLIANCE PERMIT REQUIREMENTS
OTHER BAND THEIR GENERAL FUNDS
AND AS YOU HAVE PROBABLY HEARD
FROM YOUR CONSTITUENTS CITIES
THE GENERAL FUNDS ARE VERY MUCH
UNDER STRESS STATEWIDE. BECAUSE
OF THE CONTINUED AND INCREASING
COSTS OF HAVING TO FUND PURRS I
KNOW MY CITY WHICH DID NOT GO
ABOVE THE STANDARD CLASSIC PURRS
TO PERCENT FIFTY FIVE. ARM WE
ARE LOOKING AT SEVERAL PROJECTED
YEARS OF READING.
AND WOOD THAT IS PRIMARILY DUE
TO PURRS SO THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
IT ISN'T IT IS IRRESPONSIBLE
QUITE FRANKLY FOR THE STATE
BOARDS IN THE REGIONAL BOARDS TO
IMPOSE THESE COSTS WITHOUT
KNOWING THE COST OF COMPLIANCE
FEDERAL REGULATIONS REQUIRE THAT
CITIES PROVIDE. COST OF
COMPLIANCE INFORMATION BUT
WITHOUT UNIFORM METRICS
BY WHICH TO UNDERSTAND THE
MEANING AND THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
THOSE COSTS WHAT GOOD IS THE
INFORMATION AND SO NOT
SURPRISINGLY WITH AUDIT CONFIRMS
IS AT THE REGIONAL BOARD IN THE
STATE BOARD DOES NOT PAY ANY
ATTENTION. TO THE INFORMATION
THAT'S PROVIDED BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THAT CITIES REPORT THEIR
COSTS SEPARATELY.
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
REQUIRES THE STATE BOARD TO
RESTORE PUSH THOSE FINANCIAL
REPORTING GUIDELINES AND THEN
SECONDLY IT WOULD ESTABLISH A
PILOT PROJECT BY WHICH THE
REGIONAL BOARD. WOULD APPLY
THOSE GUIDELINES IN THE SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY THE ESTIMATED
COST OF COMPLIANCE IS SIX
BILLION DOLLARS WE NEED THE
SPELL AND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COUNCILWOMAN
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE WHO WISHES
COME FOR AND SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
NOW OKAY IS THERE ANYONE MADAM
CHAIR YES A BY MAY PAUL GIVES
ALL OF US HERE REPRESENT THE
CITY OF GLENDORA WE LIKE TO
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR WHO
LEADERSHIP. ON THIS ISSUE AND WE
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL.
NOW OPPOSITION TELLING OF THIS
IS THE COMMITTEE TO BE IN TODAY
THERE'S HARDLY ANY OPPOSITION.
OKAY SINCE THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION.
USER ANY COMMENT MR MURATSUCHI.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MS RUBIO FOR
BRINGING.
THIS.
A BILL FORWARD AND AND.
TO ADDRESS THIS
VERY COMPELLING ISSUE.
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT.
THE STATE ARE.
SCREAMING FOR RELIEF.
รณ WITH THE THIS ISSUE OF A.
THE THE STORMWATER PERMIT.
DEMANDS BEING PLACED UPON THEM
WITHOUT ANY.
REAL SOLUTION AS TO HOW TO PAY
FOR IT AND SO.
I I HAVE NOT HAD A STATE
OPPORTUNITIES TO.
TO A FULLY APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
BELL AND AND AND I WILL GIVE IT
TO.
CLOSER. REVIEW BUT.
I WILL BE SUPPORTING A BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI
ANYONE ELSE FROM THE DISS IF NOT
WE NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND TO
MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND OBJECT CLOSENESS รณ
MISTER. EMMYS BACK.
THINK YOU WHILE HE'S MAKING HIS
WAY BACK UP TO THE CHAIR WOULD
YOU LIKE TO MAKE YOUR CLOTHES
EXISTE DOESN'T AND PLAIN ENGLISH
FOR MY CITIES IT WILL BANKRUPT
IBM SUPPORT PERMIT A COMPLAINTS
GOING TO BANKRUPT OF. ALL
BASICALLY ALL OF THE CITIES AND
I THINK.
SOME OF MEMBERS WHO CHEAT WE
WOULD SIT ON JAY LIKE AND WE
WERE ABLE TO INCLUDE THAT AUDIT
AT THAT. BASICALLY SAID YEAH
IT'S GOING TO BANKRUPT THE
CITIES I IT WAS JUST CONFIRMING
WHAT WE HAVE ALREADY SUSPECT
THAT AND WITH THAT I.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE OKAY GREAT THANK YOU THEN
SINCE WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND MADAM SECRETARY WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY EIGHT RUBIO.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AYE ARAMBULA.
BRO.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I.
HOLDEN.
NOT SO CHEAP MERETZ WHICH.
WE HAVE FOUR VOTES.
ASSN OVERHEAD AND CALL THAT
SOUND THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE TESTAMENT
THANK YOU.
I'M WE HAVE NEXT ITEM NUMBER
FOUR.
AB TWO FOUR FOUR SEVEN ASSEMBLY
WOMAN REYES COME ON UP TO THE
TABLE.
MISS REYES YOU HAVE THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MUST. OF
THEM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
ENGAGEMENT ON THIS ISSUE AND
EXCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
RECOMMENDED BY THE COMMITTEE.
S. DELETE SECTION TWO ONE ZERO
NINE NINE POINT FIVE FOUR FROM
THE BILL.
EXEMPT A HOUSING FROM THE PROOF
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL. AND
FURTHER CLARIFIED THE SCOPE OF
PROJECTS TO BE COMPLETE
CONSIDERED.
MEMBERS AB TWO FOUR FOUR SEVEN
WILL ENSURE THAT CRITICAL STEPS
ARE TAKEN THROUGH THE SECRET
PROCESS TO TRULY ENGAGE
COMMUNITIES.
WHICH CURRENTLY SHOULDER THE
UNDUE BURDEN OF POLLUTION.
THE CORE MESSAGE OF THIS BILL IS
SIMPLE.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD PRIORITIZE
BRINGING THE MOST VULNERABLE
GROUPS.
IN THE STATE TO THE TABLE WHEN
MAKING LOCAL LAND USE DECISIONS.
CALABAR SCREEN CURRENTLY IN ITS
THREE POINT OH VERSION IS A TOOL
THAT ALLOWS US TO BETTER
RECOGNIZE LINKAGES.
BETWEEN ENVIRONMENTAL
DEGRADATION AND POVERTY.
IN ORDER TWO INFORMED DECISION
MAKERS AND THE PUBLIC.
IF WE KNOW THAT AREAS WITHIN
THESE COMMUNITIES ARE NOT ONLY
POLLUTED BUT ALSO ME STRUGGLING
TO BE ENGAGED IN THE TRADITIONAL
SUPER PROCESS. GIVEN BARRIERS IN
PLACE FOR THE PEOPLE AND LOW
INCOME.
COMMUNITIES.
PUBLIC POLICY MAKERS SHOULD DO
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO ENGAGE
THE COMMUNITY IN THE PLANNING
PROCESS.
THIS BILL REPRESENTS A STEP TO
ENSURE THAT IN.
TO ENSURE THAT
IN WHAT.
TO ENSURE JUST THAT IN THIS
CONFUSING PROCESS.
WE NEED THE VOICES OF ALL THE
COMMUNITIES TO BE HEARD.
I HAVE WORKED WITH STAKEHOLDER
GROUPS AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO
SO IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR MOST VULNERABLE.
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ARE
BROUGHT TO THE TABLE FOR LAND
USE DECISIONS.
WITHOUT A HERE TO TO TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THIS BILL ARE DION OF
OSCARS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE.
AND ASHLEY WARNER SENIOR
ATTORNEY WITH LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
THANK YOUR SOMEONE AND REYES.
YOU HAVE TWO WITNESSES TWO
MINUTES EACH WHO WOULD LIKE TO
GO FIRST.
SANTIAGO PERSONAL GAIN RIGHT
THERE FOR MY TIME WITH MY NEXT
BOB COLLEAGUE SO MY NAME IS AND
FACE AND I'M HERE BE HAVE A
CALIFORNIA MUM'S JUST ALLIANCE.
AND WE SUPPORT THIS BILL FOR THE
REASONS THAT.
THAT WILL BE INDICATED BY MY
COLLEAGUE ACTUALLY AND GIVEN
THAT COMMUNITIES THAT SHE WORKS
AND IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
SPECIFIC IN THE CITY OF FRESNO
BUT WE FEEL AS IT ASSOCIATION
THIS IS A BILL THAT'S GOING TO
ACTUALLY AFFECT ALL CALIFORNIA'S
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND
SPECIFICALLY THE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE MOST IMPACTED BY
SPECIFICALLY FACILITIES ARE
GONNA BE EITHER BEING CITED IN
SPECIFIC AREAS SELF WITHOUT A
MINUTE TO FOR THE REST OF MY
TIME WITH ACTUALLY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AT GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK TODAY ABOUT WHY MY
ORGANIZATION AND ORGANIZATIONS
AROUND THE STATE STRONGLY
SUPPORTED AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
SEVEN. ANSWERS WAS MENTIONED MY
NAME IS ASHLEY WARNER I'M A
SENIOR ATTORNEY WITH LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY WHICH IS THIS
BILL SPONSOR. LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
WORKS ALONGSIDE HUNDREDS OF
RESIDENTS OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AND HE'S
COACHELLA VALLEY. ADVOCATE FOR
SOUND POLICY AND ERADICATE
INJUSTICE TO SECURE EQUAL ACCESS
TO OPPORTUNITY REGARDLESS OF
WEALTH RACE INCOME OR PLACE.
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL IS ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE
ALONG WITH THE CENTER ON RACE
POVERTY IN THE ENVIRONMENT WHO
ARE ALSO HERE TODAY AND WILL
SPEAK TO THE NEED FOR A MERIT OF
THIS BILL AS WELL AND. ALONG
WITH A NUMBER OF RESIDENTS FROM
KERN COUNTY WHO HAVE COME UP
SPECIFICALLY TO SPEAK ON THIS
BILL.
AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES VERY
DISPROPORTIONATE BURDEN OF
HAZARDOUS INCLUDING LAND USES
NEXT DOOR TO THEIR HOMES THEIR
SCHOOLS THEIR PARKS IN THEIR
PLACES OF WORSHIP.
THESE FACILITIES OFTEN
CONTRIBUTE TEMPERAMENTAL
DEGRADATION THROUGH THE RELEASE
OF CRITERIA AIR POLLUTANTS AND
TOXIC AIR CONTAMINANTS
FOUL ODORS WATER CONTAMINATION
AND OTHER IMPACTS WHICH IN TURN.
UNDERMINE RESIDENTS NEIGHBORHOOD
QUALITY AND ALSO CONTRIBUTED
DISPROPORTIONATELY POOR PUBLIC
HOUSE HEALTH OUTCOMES IN
IMPACTED LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR.
RESIDENTS OFTEN HAVE LITTLE OR
NO MEANINGFUL OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC INPUT ON THESE
FACILITIES BEFORE THEY ARE
APPROVED ARE CONSTRUCTED.
IN MANY CASES IT RESIDENTS ONLY
FIND OUT ABOUT THEM WHEN
CONSTRUCTION BEGINS IN FRONT OF
THEIR HOUSE.
OIL WELLS IN KERN COUNTY IN LOS
ANGELES MASSIVE WAREHOUSES AND
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE IN FRESNO
CREMATORIUMS IN RICHLAND
RICHMOND ARE ONLY A FEW
EXAMPLES.
AS A RESULT OF THE LACK OF
NOTICE AND MEANINGFUL
OPPORTUNITIES TO PROVIDE INPUT
AT THE PERSPECTIVE OF RESIDENTS
FROM THE POLLUTION THE MOST
POLLUTION BRING COMMUNITIES ARE
NOT HEARD. AND POTENTIAL PROJECT
IMPACTS AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ARE NOT CONSIDERED
OR ADDRESSED.
THAT'S DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
ARE EXCLUDED FROM THE BENEFITS
OF SEEK WAS INTENDED PURPOSE
WITCHES OF I QUOTE. TO ENSURE
THE LONG TERM PROTECTION OF THE
ENVIRONMENT CONSISTENT WITH THE
PROVISION OF A DECENT HOME AND
SUITABLE LIVING ENVIRONMENT FOR
EVERY CALIFORNIAN.
CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN GREAT
STRIDES BECOME A LEADER
NATIONWIDE IN THE MOVEMENT FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY SEVEN
PROVIDES THE NEXT STEP FORWARD
BY ENSURING THAT CALIFORNIA'S
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES HAVE
MEANINGFUL OPPORTUNITIES TO
LEARN ABOUT AND PROVIDE INPUT
SOME PROJECTS THAT MAY IMPACT
THEIR HEALTH HOMES AND
NEIGHBORHOODS. THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS SHOULD BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT AND WE THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR. MOVING THIS BILL
FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND YOU CAME IN UNDER
THE ALLOTTED TIME.
AND I'M.
IT DOESN'T HAPPEN VERY OFTEN.
AND DO WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE HERE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL NAME AND ORGANIZATION
ONLY PLEASE. A MORENO ON THE
OFFICE HERE COULD CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JUST MULLIN FOR THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MATTHEW BAKER PLAYING
CONSERVATION VAGUE AGAIN WE HAVE
NOT TAKEN OFFICIAL POSITION ON
THIS BILL BUT WE HAVE BEEN IN
CLOSE CONTACT WITH THE
PROPONENTS TO DISCUSS POTENTIAL
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS BUT WE DO
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE INTENT OF
THIS BILL HIP IN HIS FOR.
MY NAME IS FRANCISCO MENDEZ AYE
LEAVING FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND I
COME HERE TO SUPPORT THE SPIEL
BECAUSE MY COMMUNITY IS ALREADY
HAVE SO MANY.
INDUSTRIES WHO BORE LIE OR
NEIGHBORHOODS ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA.
AND I'D LIKE TO.
GET TO KNOW ABOUT.
IF IN THE OVER THERE.
I HAVE A PLAN MEETS PROPOSE.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
SPELLED NAME AND ORGANIZATION
ONLY PLEASE.
HI.
MY NAME IS ANOTHER MARKETS AND I
COME TO THE.
.
CARRY COUNTY THOUGHTS THE OTHER
SHOP SIR CITY CHAPTER.
AND I TALKED TO MY COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE MA'AM IT'S JUST.
AT THIS POINT IT'S NAME
ORGANIZATION AND WHETHER OR NOT
YOU SUPPORTER POLAKO ON SORRY
BUT THE GUY YOU'RE IN PORT THERE
RAVING OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND I'M HERE TO READ.
THEM.
CIP I'M FROM CHAPTER
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
THE NUMBERS FULLY BETTER HE YOUR
YOUNGER THAN A CORNEA THIS
CHAPTER.
YOU SEE MEN WITH BOLIVIA QUITE
OKAY.
S. THEN THERE IS THE LOCAL MONEY
THAT I THINK ABOUT THAT. MY
PURPOSE TO SEE ON A POINT I'M ON
A PROPOSED ZONE MAY BE QUITE THE
REQUIRED THEY SEE IT.
THAT'S.
SHE'S NOT A FAVOR OF MAKING SURE
THAT THE COMMUNITY HAS AWARE OF.
WHAT IS GOING TO BE HAPPENING
THE CUP COMMUNITY AND THE
SUPPORTS?
AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY SEVEN.
THAT'S.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION ONLY
PLEASE.
ON WITH THE THOUSAND IN THE
MELISSA THOUGHT ETHICAL
POLITICAL DNIA THAT'D BE. YES
THANK YOU BUT UP WE ARE UP
WITHOUT ME TO QUIT RECORDED THEY
SIT.
THANK YOU FIVE BINGO THIS HAPPY.
THE NUMBER OF A FULL HILL NC A A
SALE BUT HE DID THAT LOCAL MONEY
THAT THEY COULD YOU FEELIN. AND
VIGOROUSLY CALIFORNICUM THOUGH
THE CURRENT AND YOU'LL HAVE BEEN
UP ALL YOUR LIFE PURPOSE HAVING
TO QUIT THROWING DC AT THE.
A WHAT IS YOUR BE.
BERNIE WILLIAMS NATIONAL HOUSING
OUR PROJECT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
OKAY NOW IT'S TIME FOR THE
OPPOSITION IF THERE IS ANY
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
YOU CAN HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE
HERE FEEL LIKE TO WITNESSES TWO
MINUTES EACH
.
ADAM RIGHT HERE ON BEHALF OF.
CAO CHAMBER.
WE'RE STILL IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL BUT I WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING. HIM THE MEMORY IS IN
OUR STAFF THEY'VE COME TO THE
TABLE AND WORK WITH US
DILIGENTLY THIS BILL IS
CERTAINLY MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
WE.
APPRECIATE THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENT SPECIFICALLY THAT
REMOVES THE DISCRIMINATORY
INTENT%
AND THE FACT MANDATORY.
FINING WHICH WE FOUND TO BE
MOST PROBLEMATIC ASPECT OF THIS
BILL. AND WE SEE IT IN PRINT IT
WILL REMOVE THIS BILL OFF THE
CHAMBERS JOB TO OUR LIST.
HOWEVER.
AT WE DON'T OPPOSE THE INTENT OF
THIS BILL BUT THERE ARE SOME
SPECIFIC.
ISSUES THAT WE TAKE WITH SOME OF
THE MORE SPECIFIC SEEK WERE.
CHANGES
REGARDING HOW THEY DEFINE.
OR EXPAND THE DEFINITION OF
PROJECT UNDER SEEK WELL WE STILL
HAVE ISSUE WITH.
A.
ALLOCATING LOCAL AUTHORITY TO A
STATE AGENCY THAT DOES NOT.
TRADITIONALLY HAVE A LAND USE
POLICY MAKING EXPERIENCE
ANDERSON AMBIGUITY AROUND THAT
LANGUAGE.
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
TO.
CONTINUE TO APPROVE THIS BILL
THAT THIS TIME WERE OPPOSING
WITH MINTON.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR MEMBERS.
CASSIE GILSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND I TOO WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND HER STAFF
FOR THEIR EARLY OUTREACH AND. I
AM VERY THOROUGH ENGAGEMENT I'M
WE'RE WORKING WITH THEM ON
AMENDMENTS CLEARLY HOUSING IS
NOT THE FOCUS OF THIS BILL ADAM
AND I WERE JUST FINE TUNING
THOSE NOW AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH HER GOING FORWARD
TO GET THOSE. A PERFECTED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL WOULD LIKE TO COME
FORWARD. YET THREE MINUTES LEFT
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T USE OVER
TIME THIS WILL BE EVEN QUICKER
THAN THAT.
I'M REALLY COVERAGE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS AND I WANTED TO THINK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES FOR TAKING
INTO CONSIDERATION OUR CONCERNS.
ANDREMOVING THE PROVISIONS THAT
WOULD HAVE CREATED HOUSING IS
PERHAPS A SUBJECT LAND USE AND
SO WITH THE AMENDMENTS WE WILL
BE REMOVING OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
THINK YOU.
MARIAN WARMER DOWN THE ROAD
COUNTIES REPRESENT AS A
CALIFORNIA WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENTS THE STAFF HAS
BEEN GREAT TO WORK WITH. AND
WE'RE VERY CLOSE TO REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
REX ON MY BEHALF CALIFORNIA MS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION SHOWING
THE SAME SENTIMENTS BUT STILL
RISE RIGHT NOW OPPOSE.
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WITH THAT IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION MISTER MURATSUCHI.
THANK YOU.
IS RUBIO FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND.
FIGHTING FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE.
IT'S A.
I'M SORRY WHAT I SAY. ROUGHLY
HOME. JUSTICE HERE YEAH.
IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY. I
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT.
I DO LOOK LIKE A JONES FOR THE
SENATE SEAT MISTER HOLDEN.
THANK YOU MS WRAITHS FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE.
.
YEAH I.
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH THAT YEAH
YOU'RE.
YOUR FOCUS ON PROVIDING GREATER
NOTICE.
TO DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WE
HAD A FULL DISCUSSION ON YOUR
BILL AND THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE WHERE WE ADDRESS TO.
THAT THE SEQUEL ISSUES.
.
ARE WE RAISED THE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE. DISCRIMINATION LANGUAGE.
AND WHILE WE ARE FULLY
APPRECIATE THEY AND THEY INTEND
TO YOU KNOW THERE WERE SOME
ISSUES THAT DATA. DATA WE WERE
CONCERNED AND SO ON NINE.
GLAD TO SEE THAT YOU ARE A
WOMAN OF YOUR WORD IN THAT YOU
HAD TO TAKE OUT THAT.
.
THAT LANGUAGE BUT
IN OVERALL LOOK FOR TO. WHERE WE
KNOW THAT THE AND THE FIGHT IS
NOT OVER WITH YOUR BILL?
BUT YOUR IMPORT YOUR BILL IS A
VERY IMPORTANT STEP IN IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AND SO ON A
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND INDICATE
MY SUPPORT FOR A BILL. THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WITH ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
MR BREAUX.
THANK YOU MADAM I SHARE.
.
MY ONLY CONCERN WITH THIS IS.
TAKEN THE LOCAL CONTROL AND.
I SAT ON THE CITY COUNCIL AND.
YOU KNOW.
AS A AS A PERSON WHO SAT IN THE
COASTAL ZONE.
.
WELL AWARE OF.
THE PROCESS AND THE TIME TO
NOTIFY PEOPLE OF A CERTAIN
PROJECT.
.
SO SO THAT'S WHY COME DOWN I
THINK.
NO IF IF A PROJECT GETS APPROVED
IN A GOES UP THINK THE LOCALS
HAVE.
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE A RECOURSE
VOTE THE LOCALS OUT IF YOU DON'T
LIKE PROJECT IT WENT UP AND YOU
CAN GET NOTICE.
SO I JUST MY ISSUE IS NO ELECTED
OFFICIALS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WHO
PROBABLY KNOWS BETTER THAN WE DO
IN SACRAMENTO.
ON WHAT'S BEST FOR THEIR
COMPUTER COMMUNITY WHAT TYPE OF
PROJECTS THEY WHAT WHAT TYPE OF
PROJECTS THEY DON'T WANT. AND SO
I AS SOMEONE WHO SAT ON THE CITY
COUNCIL ON JUST GONNA.
I BELIEVE THAT UP TO LOCAL
SUICIDE PROJECTS THAT ARE GOOD
AND BAD FOR THEIR COMMUNITY SO
I'M I'M NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT IT.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER ANYONE ELSE.
QUIET ON THAT SIDE OF THE HOUSE
OKAY.
SO.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
I HAVE SOME COMMENTS AND THEN
MISTER CHAIRMAN DO YOU WANT TO
CLOSE IT UP. SO.
I THINK OF.
WELL I MEAN YOU WITH YOUR.
CLOSING IT APPEAR.
.
I WANT TO COMMEND YOU ON AND
TAKING THE STEPS NECESSARY TO
REMOVE SOME OF THE OPPOSITION I
THINK.
THAT IS A TESTAMENT TO YOUR
STICKING TO YOUR WORD. IT
APPEARS THAT THE HOUSING SIDE IS
HAPPY THAT THEY'RE NO LONGER IN
THE CROSS HAIRS BUT THE
COMMERCIAL SIDE STILL NOT SO
HAPPY BECAUSE THEY'RE STILL IN
THE CROSS HAIRS AND I THINK I.
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
ORANGE COUNTY THAT WE DON'T WANT
TO USURP LOCAL AUTHORITY.
RIGHT NO MATTER HOW MUCH
WE BELIEVE IN THE CAUSE I THINK
THERE'S A REASON WHY WE HAVE
LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS IN PLACE
WHERE THEY HAVE THE AUTHORITY
THEY DO. SAID THEY CAN DO THEIR
JOB AND WHEN THEY DON'T THEN THE
WILL OF THE PEOPLE.
TAKES OVER IN EITHER VOTES HIM
OUT OF OFFICE OR LISA MEN THERE
BECAUSE THEY'RE DOING A
WONDERFUL JOB THAT'S.
YOU NO MIKE IN TERMS TO AND I'M
SURE YOU PROBABLY FEEL THE SAME
GIVEN THAT YOU KNOW YOU HAVEN'T
ALWAYS BEEN HERE IN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY. THEM SO FOR THOSE
REASONS.
I'M NOT ABLE TO SUPPORT BILL
TABOR I DO APPRECIATE THE STEPS
YOU'VE TAKEN AND TO IMPROVE THE
BILL AND THEN I THINK. I'M IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE AND I
BELIEVE THE CHAIRMAN WILL HAVE
SOME FINAL COMMENTS AND THEN
WILL TAKE ABOUT.
WHY SURE APPRECIATE THAT THE THE
OPPORTUNITY AND?
I DID SAY WE WOULD TAKE OUT THE
DISCRIMINATION.
AND I WE TOOK CARE OF THAT
AND IT'S NO LONGER ON THE JOB
KILLER LIST AS A RESULT OF THAT.
I TOLD YOU HOUSING WAS NOT
INCLUDED WE TOOK THAT OUT NOR NO
LONGER ON THE HOUSING KILLER
LIST.
MMHM.
THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT BILL
FOR COMMUNITIES THAT SUFFER THE
MOST BECAUSE. THEY SUFFER
DISPROPORTIONATELY.
BECAUSE OF WHERE THEY ARE
BECAUSE OF THEIR PLACER ZIP CODE
BECAUSE OF THE INCOME LEVEL.
AND IT'S THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT
SHOULD HAVE NOTICE THEY SHOULD
HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY IT
SHOULDN'T BE THAT THEY OPT IN
AND THEY SAY PLEASE SEND US
NOTICE THEN THEY WILL.
BE GIVEN FURTHER NOTICE.
THEY SHOULD RECEIVE THE LETTER
SAYING WE WANT YOUR INPUT.
ADD TO THIS IS WHAT THE BILL
DOES IT PROVIDES THAT
OPPORTUNITY SO IT'S MORE
PROACTIVE APPROACH.
A SEQUEL
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
COMMUNITIES
TO GET TO GIVE INPUT.
BECAUSE WE ALREADY KNOW THAN
THEY'VE ALREADY BEEN IDENTIFIED
BY KILLING VIRAL BY KILL VIRAL
SCREEN.
.
AS THE MOST DISADVANTAGED
SO WITHOUT I THANK ALL OF YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS HERE AND THE
NATURAL RESOURCES.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE.
ALRIGHT AYE MADAM SECRETARY
WOULD YOU PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE
OR A MISTER QUIRK.
YOU'RE SO QUIET OVER THERE IT
YEAH.
I HAVE TO BE.
รณ FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO
SAY THE ONLY THING THIS BILL
DOES IS REQUIRED NOTICE.
AND SO.
BEAR WITH ME.
IT IS.
THE MUSIC PLAYING IN BETWEEN
I KNOW HOW.
UP IT ONLY REQUIRES NOTICE.
PERIOD IT TAKES NO DISCRETION
AWAY FROM THE LOCALS.
ARM FRANKLY IN HAYWARD WE ALWAYS
GAVE NOTICE TO PEOPLE WHO WERE
NEARBY PERIOD A LOT COMMUNITIES
DO THIS BUT SOME DON'T.
I WILL ALSO SAY THAT
COMMUNITIES OF.
.
THAT ARE WELL ESTABLISHED.
ARM ART IN POVERTY TEND TO HAVE
NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATIONS HAVE
ASKED OFTEN.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT POOR
COMMUNITIES.
THAT MAY NOT HAVE SOMEONE IN
THAT COMMUNITY WHO HAS OPTED IN
TO GET THESE NOTICES.
AND THAT IS ALL THIS DOES AND.
AND THE OPPOSITION HER CAR
CORRECT ME BUT I BELIEVE THE
ONLY THING THEY'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT.
IS A BETTER DEFINITION.
OF. WHAT SORT OF FIRM?
?
PROJECTS WOULD REQUIRE THE
NOTICE IS THAT CORRECT.
WELL.
WHO DETERMINES WHAT A SUBJECT
LAND USE IS IS TO A STATE AGENCY
WE ARE AND THERE'S SOME
AMBIGUITY AS TO THE DIRECTION
THIS BILL PROVIDES TO A STATE
AGENCY SO? AS TO WHO GETS THE
NOTICES THERE'D WHAT IS
ENCOMPASSED UNDER SUBJECT LAND
USE.
THAT IS ALLOCATED NOW TO STATE
AGENCIES AS OPPOSED TO A LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS GOT AND MAYBE THAT
THAT THAT THE DIFFICULTY WE
HAVE.
IS NOT EVERYONE DEFINES
INDUSTRIAL USES THE SAME WAY.
ARM A WAREHOUSE THAT HAS A LOT
OF TRUCKS COMING IN AND OUT.
ME NOT BE DEFINED AS INDUSTRIAL.
ARM.
CERTAINLY IF THE AUTHOR IS ABLE.
COME UP WITH A LIST OF USES
OUR THAT WOULD BE BEST.
ARM IF YOU CAN SUGGEST.
A DIFFERENT WAY OF OF.
DEFINING KNEES WE WOULD
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE IT.
ARM AND THAT IT WOULD BE. BEST
IF WE DIDN'T HAVE TO GO TO A
STATE AGENCY TO FIND.
ARM AND THAT IS SOMETHING THE
AUTHOR I KNOW WANTS TO WORK ON.
STARTING YOUR HEAD YES.
SO I THINK WE WILL BE ABLE.
TO COME UP WITH A.
SATISFACTORY DEFINITION I HOPE
WE DON'T HAVE TO GO TO A STATE
AGENCY BUT IF WE DO WILL MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE GOOD LANGUAGE
AND WILL BE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR ON THAT.
AND.
AGAIN IF YOU SUGGEST A
DIFFERENT AGENCY THAT'S
SOMETHING WE CAN CERTAINLY LOOK
AT. BUT WE DON'T WANT SOMEBODY
TO AVOID.
THE NOTICE REQUIREMENT BY
SAYING รณ THIS IS AN INDUSTRIAL
WITH SOMETHING ELSE AND THAT'S.
THAT'S THE ONLY REASON WE JUST
DIDN'T SAY INDUSTRIAL IN S. SO
IT'S A REAL PROBLEM AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE TIME TO
WORK ON AND IF.
.
IF YOU'RE WILLING TO WORK WITH
US TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR I
HOPE WE CAN COME UP WITH A
SATISFACTORY SOLUTION.
SO.
I'M VERY MUCH IN FAVOR OF THIS
AS I SAID SOME COMMUNITIES DO
THIS SOME DON'T.
I THINK IT IS VERY IMPORTANT IN
AGAIN ALL WE'RE TALKING THAT AS
NOTICE
IF NO ONE WAS WORRIED ABOUT IT.
THERE WON'T EVEN BE AN IMPACT
AND IF PEOPLE ARE.
THEN AS SOMEONE SAID HERE THEY
BETTER LISTEN TO THEIR
CONSTITUENTS.
ALRIGHT.
WITH THAT.
I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER FOUR EIGHT
BE TWENTY FOUR FORTY SEVEN
ANDREAS THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
QUIRK.
I QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NO ARAMBULA.
PRO.
BRUNO.
BLUE.
BLOOM BY.
HOLDEN.
WHAT AT SOCHI?
MATTEUCCI I.
THE VOTE STANDS NOW AT THREE TO
TWO.
THANK YOU.
THAT BILL IS ON CALL FOR NOW IN
THE LAST BILL WE HAVE.
IS MISTER BLOOM.
.
VIOLATED NUMBER TWO AB TWO THREE
SEVEN NINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I ACCEPT.
ALL LOOK THE COMMITTEES
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS.
THANK CA YOUR STAFF FOR.
SOME VERY TEDIOUS AND HARD WORK
ON THIS BILL.
CLOTHING MADE FROM SYNTHETIC
FABRICS DOMINATES THE CLOTHING
INDUSTRY AND AS A RESULT
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE REGULARLY
WASH CLOTHES THAT ARE MADE OF
SYNTHETIC MATERIAL THE CLOTHING
I'M WEARING IS NO DIFFERENT IN
FACT. ABOUT SIXTY PERCENT OF
FABRIC PRODUCED IN THE TEXTILE
INDUSTRY IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
CONTAIN POLYESTER.
AND WASHING CLOTHING MADE FROM
THESE SYNTHETIC FABRICS.
WE NOW KNOW RELEASES PLASTIC
MICROFIBER IS THAT MAKE THEIR
WAY INTO OUR WATER AND THEREIN
LIES THE PROBLEM.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN THE REGIONAL
MONITORING PROGRAM FOR WATER
QUALITY IN SAN FRANCISCO BAY.
TESTED THE EFFLUENT OF EIGHT
WASTE WATER TREATMENT PLANTS AND
FOUND THAT EIGHTY PERCENT.
OF THE MICRO PLASTICS THAT THEY
FOUND ANOTHER MICROSCOPIC
PARTICLES WERE IN FACT SMALL
FIBERS FROM CLOTHING.
EVERY TIME A FLEECE JACKET IS
WASHED IT RELEASES HUNDREDS IF
NOT THOUSANDS OF FIBERS AND TO
GET AN IDEA OF THE SCALE OF THIS
PROBLEM. THE AMOUNT OF PLASTIC
RELEASED BY THE LAUNDERING OF
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND FLEECE
JACKETS. IS EQUIVALENT TO UP TO
NEARLY TWELVE HUNDRED PLASTIC
GROCERY BAGS
AND THIS IS ACCORDING TO A STUDY
FROM UC SANTA BARBARA. BRAND
SCHOOL OF ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCE
AND MANAGEMENT THAT WAS
COMMISSIONED BY THE PATAGONIA
COMPANY IN TWENTY SIXTEEN.
STANDARD WASHING MACHINES DO NOT
HAVE FILTERS TO CATCH THESE
FIBERS AND ONCE THEY ESCAPE FROM
OUR LAUNDRY THE TINY MOBILE
THREATS WORKED OUR WAY TO OUR
WASTE WATER TREATMENT PLANTS.
THEIR FILTERS DON'T CATCH THE
FIBERS EITHER AND AS A RESULT IT
IS ESTIMATED THAT SYNTHETIC
FIBERS ARE BY COUNT. NOW THE
SINGLE LARGEST CONTRIBUTOR TO
WATERSHED PLASTIC POLLUTION IN
DEVELOPED COUNTRIES AND ACCOUNT
FOR A SIGNIFICANT PORTION.
PLASTIC WASTE ENTERING THE
OCEAN.
WE DON'T KNOW YET THE EXTENT TO
WHICH MICHAEL PLASTIC POLLUTION
MIGHT AFFECT HUMANS.
WE DO KNOW THAT MANY ANIMALS
WITHIN THE AQUATIC FOOD CHAIN
INGEST THESE PLASTICS.
THIS CAN TRANSFER TO THEIR
TISSUE AND BECAUSE GOD IMPACTION
HORMONE DISRUPTION AND LIVER
DAMAGE.
MEANING WE ARE ALSO INGESTING
PLASTIC MICROFIBER IS IF WE EAT.
THOSE OF FISH AS FOOD.
THIS RAISES AN IMPORTANT
QUESTION ABOUT THE HUMAN HEALTH
CONSEQUENCES OF UNINTENDED.
CONSUMPTION OF PLASTIC
MICROFIBER STE.
YOU SEE DAVIS SAMPLED FISH AND
SHELLFISH SOLD LOCAL.
CALIFORNIA AT A LOCAL CALIFORNIA
FISH MARKET AND FOUND ONE
QUARTER OF THE FISSION ONE THIRD
OF THE SHELLFISH.
UNTAMED PLASTIC DEBRIS MOST OF
THAT MICRO FIBERS.
SIMILARLY A SURVEY COMPARED ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TAP WATER
SAMPLES FROM LOCATIONS IN FIVE
CONTINENTS.
AND MICHAEL PLASTIC FIBERS WERE
FOUND IN EVERY NEARLY EVERY
SAMPLE.
NINETY FOUR PERCENT OF THE
UNITED STATES WATER SAMPLES
CONTAINED PLASTIC MICROFIBER
SITS.
SCIENTISTS ARE FINDING THAT EVEN
BOTTLED WATER IS CONTAMINATED
WITH MICHAEL FIBERS.
NOW IF YOU THINK ABOUT BOTTLED
WATER THIS IS WATER THAT GOES
THROUGH A VERY EXTENSIVE
FILTRATION PROCESS.
RESEARCHERS RECENTLY EXAMINED
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY BOTTLES OF
WATER SOLD BY MAJOR BRANDS. AND
BOUGHT IN AND AND AND BOUGHT IN
NINE DIFFERENT COUNTRIES.
THE RESULTS
NINETY THREE PERCENT OF THE
TESTED WATERS SHOWED SIGNS OF
MICHAEL PLASTIC CONTAMINATION.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY NINE
REQUIRES THAT NEW CLOTHING MADE
PRIMARILY OF PLASTIC BE LABELED
TO INDICATE THAT.
THE IF THE LABEL TO END THE
INDICATE THAT THE GARMENT SHEDS
PLASTIC MICROFIBER IS WHEN
WASHED.
AND THAT THAT CONTRIBUTES TO
MARINE PLASTIC POLLUTION AND
THAT LANGUAGE WHILE NOT EXACT
THAT IS PART OF THE MOST RECENT
AMENDMENT TO THIS BILL SO THE
LANGUAGE SIMPLY.
INFORMS PEOPLE ABOUT THE.
A MICROFIBER PROBLEM AND THAT
MICROFIBER IS ARE CONTRIBUTING
TO MARINE POLLUTION.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY NINE I
SHOULD POINT OUT IS NOT A BAND
BUT IT IS AN IMPORTANT FIRST
STEP THAT EDUCATES THE PUBLIC
AND WILL HELP MOVE
MANUFACTURERS.
TOWARDS FINDING A LASTING
SOLUTION WHICH IS WHAT WE REALLY
SHOULD BE LOOKING FOR.
I HAVE THREE WITNESSES WITH ME
HERE TODAY JENNIFER WILLIAMS
WITH THESE BAY MUD. ON.
NOT TERRORISM FROM STOP WASTE
AND MELISSA ROMERO WITH
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM ON
THAT THE. COMMITTEE POLICIES TO
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH SO DO
YOU WANT TO DIVIDE UP YOUR FOUR
MINUTES AMONG THE THREE YEARS
ARE ONLY TWO THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY.
YOU DIVIDE UP THE TIME OKAY OFF
YOU GO WHO WANTS TO GO FIRST.
AND COME UP.
MISTER CHAIR MADAM VICE
CHAIRMAN IN JENNIFER WILLIAMSON
WITH THE EAST BAY MUNICIPAL
UTILITY DISTRICT. IN THE MIND OF
THE WATER AND WASTEWATER
TREATMENT PROVIDER.
IN EAST BAY WE PROVIDE
WASTEWATER TREATMENT SERVICES TO
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND CUSTOMERS IN OUR
SERVICE AREA. AND I'M HERE NAY
TODAY TO TO SO TO SUPPORT AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY NINE. SOME
WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S WORK
ON THE ISSUE OF PREVENTING
PLASTIC PARA POLLUTION AND HAVE
SUPPORTED PRIOR BELT FROM ON THE
PLASTIC MICROBEADS ISSUES.
TODAY WITH AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY NINE IT'S BEEN MENTIONED
THAT THE PLASTIC MICROFIBER IS
OUR SMALL PLASTIC FIBERS FOUND
IN SYNTHETIC FABRIC INCLUDING
CLOTHING. THESE MICRO FIBERS ARE
EXTREMELY SMALL AND ONCE WASHED
DOWN THE DRAIN MAKE THEIR WAY TO
WASTE WATER TREATMENT SYSTEMS
WHICH ARE NOT DESIGNED TO TREAT
AT THESE PLASTIC MICRO FIBERS.
SO THE MICRO FIBERS MAY
ULTIMATELY REACH WATERWAYS AND
THE OCEAN CONTRIBUTE
CONTRIBUTING TO THE ACCUMULATION
OF PLASTIC AT MARINE DEBRIS.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY NINE.
LABELING REQUIREMENTS WOULD HELP
CONSUMERS MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS ABOUT THE PURCHASE AS
WELL AS THE CLEANING AND CARE OF
THE CLOTHING MADE FROM SYNTHETIC
MATERIAL. AND HELP PREVENT
POLLUTION OF WATER BODIES THAT
RECEIVE WASTEWATER DISCHARGE
SO FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M UNDER
NITROGEN AND I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF STOP WASTE.
I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH A MEMBER
AGENCIES WHICH INCLUDES FORKING
CITIES THREE SANITARY DISTRICT
IN THE COUNTY ITSELF. WE HAVE
CONTINUED TO PLACE EMPHASIS ON
WASTE PREVENTION OVER MANAGEMENT
OF THE SCARVES AND WORKING ON
UPSTREAM SOLUTIONS. WITH A FOCUS
ON CREATING AWARENESS THROUGH
EDUCATION AND PUBLIC
COMMUNICATION.
TO PROVIDE THE INFORMATION TO I
RESIDENTS TO HELP THEM MAKE
CONSCIOUS PURCHASING CHOICES.
THIS BILL DOES JUST THAT IT
PROVIDES.
.
MEMBERS COMMUNITY MEMBERS THE
ABILITY TO MAKE CHOICES.
.
WITH THE UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
THE GETTING INTO.
THIS IS CERTAINLY A FIRST STEP A
AND LEAVING WILL RAISE THE
AWARENESS TO MITIGATE THE ISSUE.
WE REALIZE THAT EMERGING
TECHNOLOGY CAN HELP MITIGATE
THIS FURTHER.
OF BUT AGAIN AS WE SAID GIVING
PEOPLE THE CHOICE IS OUR FIRST
STEP
A TACKLE THIS CHALLENGE. UP
CONSUMPTION BEHAVIOR NEEDS TO
CHANGE NEW MATERIALS THAT DON'T
SHED NEED TO BE DEVELOPED
WASHING MACHINES NEED TO INCLUDE
PHOTOS TO CAPTURE FIGHTERS.
AND WHICH TREATMENT PLANS NEED
TO BE UPDATED AND ALL THAT THIS
CAN CONTINUE TO BE DONE AND THIS
BILL DOES NOT PRECLUDE ANY OF
THOSE FROM MOVING FORWARD.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS AND FOR THE
REASONS THAT WE AT STOP WASTE
BELIEVE A AND IN PUBLIC OF.
EDUCATION AND COMMUNICATION WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL AND.
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF IT AS WELL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MELISSA ROMERO
WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE PROUD
CO SPONSOR OF THE BILL. AS THE
ANNOUNCES POINTED OUT THERE IS
NO DEBATE OVER WHETHER
MICROFIBER POLLUTION IS A
PROBLEM OR WHETHER WASHING
CLOTHING MADE FROM SYNTHETIC
TEXTILES CONTRIBUTES TO THAT
PROBLEM. THE SCIENTIFIC PROOF IS
UNDENIABLE THE SCIENCE SHOWS US
THAT OUR SEAFOOD TAP WATER AND
BOTTLED WATER CONTAINS MICRO
FIBERS AND PEOPLE DESERVE TO
KNOW THAT THEIR CLOTHING IS MADE
FROM PLASTIC. AND THAT THEIR
PURCHASING IN LAUNDRY HABITS
HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO CONTRIBUTE
TO THE MOST PERVASIVE TYPE.
PLASTIC POLLUTION MICROFIBER
POLLUTION.
RECENT HISTORY SHOWN US THAT
CALIFORNIANS OF ALL
SOCIOECONOMIC STATUSES CULTURES
AND AGES CARE ABOUT REDUCING
MICRO ARE SORRY PLASTIC
POLLUTION. IT'S TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA TO ADDRESSED
MICROFIBER POLLUTION WHICH
DWARFS ALL OTHER CATEGORIES OF
PLASTIC POLLUTION IN THE
ENVIRONMENT AND ULTIMATELY IN
OUR FOOD AND DRINKING WATER. AND
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A WHO ELSE
WOULD LIKE TO COME FORWARD AND
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
NAME AND ORGANIZATIONALLY
PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS JUST HER DOG WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SANITATION AGENCIES HERE IT'S
PART. THANK YOU.
A MARINE ON BEHALF OF CIRCLE
CALIFORNIA HE'LL BANG CLEAN
WATER ACTION.
THANK YOU.
GENEVIEVE ABATTANT ON BEHALF OF.
SURFRIDER FOUNDATION PLASTIC
POLLUTION COALITION WILD COAST
ZERO WASTE USA SEVENTH
GENERATION.
ADVISORS.
THE FIVE TEARS INSTITUTE. CENTER
FOR OCEANIC AWARENESS RESEARCH
AND EDUCATION UPSTREAM POLICY
AND WISH TOYOTA CHUMASH
FOUNDATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JUST MALANA
BEHOFF OF HOG ISLAND OYSTER
COMPANY WE ONE OF THE OYSTER
GROWERS THAT ARE IMPACTED BY
THIS AND IT'S VERY TROUBLING.
THANK YOU.
I MEAN TO OUR BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AT THIS
POINT WILL BRING UP ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SAME POLICY TO WITNESSES TWO
MINUTES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MARGARET
CLUTCHING A BEHALF CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION OF I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR BRING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND WE'VE HAD SOME
ROBUST DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE CHAIR.
APPRECIATE THE TO AMENDMENT SAFE
TAKEN WE DO THINK THEY REYES
THAT THAT MIGHT RIVERS ARE AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE BUT WE DON'T
THINK MANDATORY LABELING AT
POINT OF SALE IS THE APPROPRIATE
SOLUTION.
EVEN WITH THE CHANGES THE
AUTHOR ACCEPTED TODAY THIS BILL
HAS TREMENDOUS LIABILITY FOR
RETAILERS AND IT'S PREMATURE
ACCORDING TO THE BRAND SCHOOL OF
ENVIRONMENTAL STUDIES WHO
CONVENED A MICROFIBER SUMMIT
LAST FALL THEY'RE STILL
IDENTIFYING AND REPRIMAND
ACKNOWLEDGED KNOWLEDGE GAPS IN
WHAT THE MAJOR SOURCES OF
MICROFIBER. FIBER POLLUTION ARE.
DO WE THINK THIS BILL AS A
MANDATORY LABELING CREATES
LIABILITY FOR CONSUMERS AND IT
REQUIRES NOT ONE A SORRY FOR
RETAILERS REQUIRES NOT ONE BUT
TO.
DIFFERENT LABELS THAT WE DON'T
THINK WE'LL HAVE AN IMPACT ON
THE CONSUMERS EITHER PURCHASING
OR WASHING HABITS.
.
SO I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT
CONSUMER LIKE THIS CONSUMERS
LIKE THESE MATERIALS AND AND
CLOTHING MADE OUT OF THEM
THEY'RE OFTEN VERY DURABLE AND
LESS EXPENSIVE. THAN A CLOTHING
MADE OUT OF WOOL COTTON OR.
LINEN OR OTHER NATURAL MATERIALS
IN FACT THOSE MATERIALS MAY HAVE
DIFFERENT ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS
SUCH AS MORE WATER YEARS.
AND.
.
AND PRODUCING THEM DOESN'T
NECESSARILY THAT CREATES OTHER
PROBLEMS THAT THIS COMMITTEE HAS
BEEN WELL AWARE OF.
FINALLY I WOULD ARGUE THAT
ANOTHER LABEL ON CLOTHING ADS
HAVE KIT WHICH CONSUMERS WILL
THROW WEIGHT DOES ADD TO THE
WASTE STREAM WHICH IS SOMETHING
I WOULD ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU TO
BE SENSITIVE ABOUT OF WHAT AS
WELL. SO FOR ALL THESE REASONS
THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION ASK FOR NOVA.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
BURST ON CAP KEY MCCUE CAP CAN
ASSOCIATE SOME HELP THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. I'VE. FOR
THE REASONS STATED BY MS CLOUD
STEAM NAM FOR MANUFACTURING
PERSPECTIVE THE US CERTAINLY
THIS WOULD BE AN ADDED COST AND
TIME CONSTRAINT. TO INSURE THAT
THESE ARE NOT JUST ONE LABEL BUT
TO I'M THINKING TAGS AT WHAT
HAVE YOU. ARE AFFIXED TO EACH
CLOTHING ITEM FURTHER QUESTIONS
ABOUT LIABILITY ON MEN WHO THAT
LIABILITY EXTENDS TO REFER
MANUFACTURE WERE TO BE ABLE TO
COMPLY WITH SUCH PROVISIONS
REQUIREMENTS. IN THEN I SHIPS
OF SHIPS THOSE MEN ARE CLOTHING
ITEMS TO A RETAILER. AND IF A
PARTICULAR I HANG TAG COMES OFF
OF A PARTICULAR ITEM OR THEY
THEN IN VIOLATION ASSOCIATED
WITHOUT THAT PARTICULAR CLOTHING
ITEM. ARM AND THE REQUIREMENTS.
WITH THAT LIABILITY FUND THE
RETAILER THE MANUFACTURER BOTH A
LOT OF CONCERNS ABOUT THE ATEN
AS MISS GOD SEEN THE AND NOTED
ON ALSO JUST QUESTION NOT FROM A
POLICY PERSPECTIVE. THE BENEFIT
OF THOSE BECAUSE WE DO BELIEVE
THAT GOT CONSUMERS TO FIND GREAT
VALUE IN THESE PARTICULAR
CLOTHING OPTIONS OB COST
EFFECTIVE BEEN MENDOZA CERTAINLY
FUNCTIONAL. I WOULD JUST ARGUE
ON THAT SIDE THAT'S NOT
NECESSARILY THE BEST WAY TO
IMPACTS CHECK OUT THE CONCERNS
AND ISSUES. ON AND WE JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK THROUGH NOVO
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANY
OTHER OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL IF
THERE IS PLEASE COME FORWARD.
MADAM VICE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE RAINY PARK AND WE
HAVE THE AMERICAN CHEMISTRY
COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION.
MAN VICE CHAIR MEMBERS COMMITTEE
JOE ACT OR BEHAVE THE PLASTICS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION OPPOSED.
THANK YOU.
MELISSA WARNER ON BEHALF OF THE
RETAIL INDUSTRY LEADERS
ASSOCIATION AND OPPOSITION.
OUR EIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE ELSE. OKAY THEN WILL
BRING IN APPEAR TO THE DANCE
ANYWHERE ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
NONE OKAY.
.
WHAT I HAVE A COUPLE OF QUICK
THANK YOU YOU CAN GET AND I HAVE
A COUPLE OF COMMENTS WE ARE HE
SAW THIS BILL A NATURAL
RESOURCES AND HAD A VERY LENGTHY
DEBATE? ON THIS BILL AND SINCE
THAT TIME YOU HAVE MADE SOME
CHANGES IN THE REQUIREMENTS ON
MANUFACTURERS WITH RESPECT TO.
AYE THE LABELING REQUIREMENTS
WHICH WHICH IS IT'S GOOD AND BAD
BECAUSE I THINK ORIGINALLY THEY
HAD TO PUT ON THERE THAT THEY
WOULD RELEASE MICRO FIBERS AND
THAT IT SHOULD BE HAND WASHED.
I MAN THAT IS SINCE BEEN
REMOVED.
.
SO.
FOR ME WHEN.
WHEN YOU SAY.
THIS.
MATERIAL MAY RELEASE MICRO
FIBERS BUT YOU DON'T
TELL THE CONSUMER WHAT THEY
SHOULD DO ABOUT THAT THEN I AM
KINDA LEFT TO WONDER WALL WILL
THAT CHANGE ANYTHING WILL THEY
EVEN READ IT.
SOME WELL BECAUSE THEY'RE A
LITTLE MORE IN TUNE WITH.
THIS TYPE OF ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUE
BUT MANY OTHERS WILL NOT.
.
IT WOULD BE GREAT IF.
THE MANUFACTURING WORLD WOULD
COME UP WITH SOMETHING THAT
PERHAPS COULD BE MADE PART OF
OUR WASHING MACHINES THAT COULD
YOU KNOW CATCH THE SORT OF
PARTICLES.
THAT HASN'T HAPPENED YET I'M A
LITTLE SURPRISED I HAVEN'T SEEN
SOMEONE ON SHARK TANK WITH SOME
GREAT IDEA OF YOU KNOW HOW TO DO
THIS TO MAKE A ZILLION DOLLARS.
.
BUT THAT HASN'T HAPPENED YET SO.
I SHARE YOUR CONCERN.
ABOUT
THESE PARTICLES GOING INTO OUR
WATERWAYS IN THE ENVIRONMENT I
REALLY DO.
WOULD BE GREAT IF EVERYBODY
WERE NATURAL A ARE YOU KNOW
GARMENTS BUT THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN
AND I'M JUST NOT CONVINCED THAT.
LABEL IT LABELING IT BY SAYING
THAT IT RELEASES THESE MICRO
FIBERS WILL NECESSARILY GET
PEOPLE TO ACT.
DIFFERENTLY.
.
SO I DON'T KNOW IF THIS BILL IS
GONNA CHANGE AT ALL ONCE IT
MOVES FROM HERE BUT I JUST WANT
YOU KNOW THAT I DO SUPPORT. ON
YOUR EFFORTS I'D.
I JUST DON'T SUPPORT THIS
PARTICULAR BILL BECAUSE I'M NOT
CONVINCED IT WILL ACTUALLY
CHANGE CONSUMER. BEHAVIOR BUT I
HOPE.
I HOPE THAT CHANGES IN THE
FUTURE WHERE YOU AND I CAN CAN
PARTNER IN ONE OF THESE THEM
BELL SO. WITH THAT BEING SAID
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AND THEN
I BELIEVE THE CHAIRMAN AND WILL
HAVE SOME COMMENTS.
THANK YOU.
I THINK THAT THE A LABELING
LANGUAGE COULD TELL YOU SOME
IMPROVEMENTS I THINK WE'RE IN
AGREEMENT DARREN WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK ON.
OF THE SPECIFIC LANGUAGE OF THE
BILL AS IT MOVES FORWARD TO TO
PASS OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE TODAY
BUT TARA I THINK MADAM VICE
CHAIR YOU JUST KIND OF PUT YOUR
FINGER ON. ON WHAT TO ADD THE
FIRST STEP NEEDS TO BE HERE ON
AN ISSUE LIKE THIS AND THAT'S
RAISING AWARENESS THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT THESE LABELS ARE INTENDED
TO DO.
OF YOUR CORRECT WE DON'T KNOW
ENOUGH.
BUT WE KNOW ENOUGH TO KNOW THAT
THIS IS A VERY SERIOUS PROBLEM.
WE KNOW THAT TO SOME LAUNDERING
STRATEGIES ARE BETTER THAN
OTHERS.
BUT THE NUMBER ONE THING THAT
THE PUBLIC NEEDS IS AWARENESS ON
THIS ISSUE WITH SO THAT WE CAN
BEGIN TO THINK ABOUT IT. AND
THAT WILL LEAD TO PEOPLE HAVE
NOW TO SHARK TANK IN THE.
PRODUCING GOT EVEN BETTER
SOLUTIONS FORCE BUT AWARENESS IS
KEY. AND THAT WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
CHAU THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
WORKING WITH US.
ARM
I DO THINK THAT WHAT WE'VE DONE
IN TERMS OF LIABILITY DOES
LIMIT.
TREMENDOUSLY THE AMOUNT OF
LIABILITY WHAT WHAT DO THERE I
NOR THE AUTHOR WANTED.
WAS FOR SOMEBODY TO HAVE BE FINE
BECAUSE THE TAG FELL OFF.
WITH ONLY ALLOWING DEA'S AG'S.
.
TO PURSUE THIS AND SINCE THEY
HAVE A LOT OF OTHER THINGS TO
DO.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THEY WOULD
DO SOMETHING UNLESS
ARE. THE RETAILER WERE NOT.
TO. NOT PUT LABELS ON AT ALL OR
THAT MANUFACTURER WE'RE NOT TO
PUT LABELS ON AT ALL. AND THAT
WAS THE INTENTION OF THAT
AMENDMENT AND I THINK THAT DOES
LIMIT THE LIABILITY.
AS S. B. AUTHOR SAID WE DON'T
HAVE A SOLUTION. THIS IS A WAY
TO GET PEOPLE TO REALIZE
SOMETHING THIS NEEDS TO BE DONE
SO WE CAN GET SOMEONE SHARK TANK
TARA COME UP WITH A SOLUTION.
ARM SO.
THAT IT.
AND THE REASON WHY.
WASH HAND WASH CAME OFF HIS
WHICH IS NOT SURE HOW MUCH THAT
WOULD HELP EITHER SO. THERE'S A
LOT TO BE LEARNED AND I THINK
THE FIRST STEP IS EDUCATION.
I'M A SCIENTIST
I HAD NO IDEA ABOUT THIS UNTIL
THIS BILL CAME UP.
CELL AND I I FOLLOW A LOT OF
STUFF.
SO.
PLEASE VOTE ONLY.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY NINE BLOOM.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE FLOOR.
QUIRK.
QUIRK I.
MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NO ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BROKE.
BRUNO.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I.
HOLDEN.
WELL THAT'S WHAT SHE.
WHAT AT SWITCHING?
FORTY TWO.
CONGRATULATIONS YOUR BILL IS
OUT.
YOU THINK IT'S GOING ALRIGHT
THEN IF THE SERGEANT CAN SOMEHOW
CONTACT MISTER HOLDEN.
AND LET US AND IN HE COULD LET
US KNOW HOW SOON WE CAN GET BACK
HERE I WILL HOPE TO BE ABLE TO
STAY UNTIL HE GETS BACK.
IN THE MEANTIME LET'S.
FOR THE MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE
LET'S GO THROUGH.
BE YEAH.
THE BILLS AND GET THE ADD ONS
AND.
HOPEFULLY.
.
RESOLVE ALL THE BILL'S THEY'RE
ON CALL WHICH I THINK WE WELL.
SO GO IN ORDER ON FILE ORDER SO
THE NEXT BILL IS.
ITEM NUMBER THREE IT'S AB
TWENTY FOUR OH SEVEN TAKING. THE
VOTE STANDS AT FOUR ZERO.
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE AND
THE VICE CHARITY OF VOTING AYE.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I.
BRO.
BRUNO.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I.
SO THAT OUT SIX TO ONE.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY SEVEN ANDREAS.
.
THE CHAIR VOTED AYE IN THE VOTE
STANDS AT THREE TO TWO.
ADEMOLA.
ARAMBULA I.
HOLDEN.
.
GHOST AFFORDED USE THAT WENT
OUT.
THE EXPOS ITEM NUMBER FIVE IT'S
AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY FOUR
QUIRK.
THE VOTES STANDS AT FOUR ZERO
WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR OF
BOTH VOTING AYE.
A ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA I. BROKE.
BROKE AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE SO THAT'S OUT
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER SIX. AB
TWENTY FIVE A ONE CHIU.
THE VOTE STANDS AT FIVE TWO ZERO
OF BOTH CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I.
BLOOM.
WHEN I SAY AGAIN THAT VOTE
SEVEN TWO ZERO.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN IS AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT RUBIO.
THE VOTE IS AT FOUR ZERO AGAIN
WITH A TOUCH OF A CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BROKE.
BRO I.
SO THAT IS ON AND WERE WAITING
ON HOLDEN SO IT'S AT THE VOTE
STANDS AT SIX
ZERO.
THE POINT.
SO THIS IS ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN QUIRK
A MAY GO AHEAD AND.
TO SPUR CLARITY I READ THE
MOTION THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
BOTH OF CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTED AYE AS WELL AS.
HOLDEN AND WHAT IT'S ACHIEVED
FOR THE VOTES STANDS AT FOUR
ZERO.
I'M GLAD.
ARAMBULA AYE. BRO.
BRO NO BLOOM.
BLOOM I.
SO THAT VOTE
FINAL VOTE IS SIX TWO ONE.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER NINE AB
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTEEN MORE AT
SUCH A.
THE VOTE STANDS AT THREE ZERO.
ON.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I NOW.
SARAH.
AND THAT BELLA'S OUT.
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY NINE
THIRTY FOUR MARK STONE.
THE VOTE STANDS AT THREE ZERO.
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE. AND OTHER
VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BRO.
PEROT IS NOT VOTING.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I
SO THE VOTE IS
FIVE ZERO FINAL VOTE AND THAT
BILL IS OUT AS WELL.
I WOULD JUST WAITING ON ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN ON A FEW BELLS
THANK YOU.
YES AND I'LL WAY TED รณ TEN
MINUTES OR SO UNTIL MISTER
HOLDING CAN GET HERE.
VOTING RIGHT NOW.
STUFF JUST.
WHAT'S NEXT.
THANK YOU
SO MISSED YOUR HOLDING THIS
BACK.
I GOT VERY UPSET THE OTHER DAY
WHEN I WAS PRESENTING THE BILL.
AND COMMITTEE PACKED UP WITHOUT
ME.
EVERYTHING IT PASSED SO IT
DIDN'T MATTER BUT.
STILL I I. I WOULD HAVE FELT
YOUR PAIN SO WE DEFINITELY WANT
YOU HERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I APPRECIATE
THAT AND YOU ARE ONE OF OUR
BETTER MEMBERS IN TERMS OF BEING
HERE SO I PARTICULARLY WANTED TO
MAKE SURE YOU GOT A CHANCE TO
VOTE I ALWAYS WANTED HERE TO
HAVE A CORE.
THANK YOU.
SO WE'RE GONNA GO OVER THREE
BELLS.
ITEM NUMBER TWO IS AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY NINE BLOOM.
AND THE CHAIR VOTED AYE THE VICE
CHAIR VOTED NO IN THE VOTES
STANDS AT FOURTEEN. HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
SO THAT BRINGS THE VOTE FINAL
VOTE TWO FIVE TWO ON THAT BILL.
THE NEXT BILL.
IS ITEM NUMBER FOUR.
AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY SEVEN.
ANDREAS AND THE VOTES. AT FOUR
TO.
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE AND
THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
HOLDEN ON HOLDEN AYE SO THAT
BRINGS THE VOTE FINAL VOTE TWO
FIVE TO TWO.
GLASPELL IS ITEM NUMBER SEVEN.
AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
RUBIO.
THAT VOTE STANDS AT SIX ZERO
WITH BOTH THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE SO THAT IS FINAL VOTE
SEVEN ZERO.
THANK YOU.
NOW WE HAVE A VERY.
OH YEAH KEVIN.
ALRIGHT WE ARE DONE THANK YOU